[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right all right
round what's going on how my levels are
signing what's going on
craig hooligan what's going on dovie
what up
stuff showing what's going on only on
xbox what's up general mack what's going
on cute tang clan got that gym in i like
that health as well
necromancer zale what's up back today
what's going on mexican zoidberg member
for 13 months legendary podcast long
live the iron lords you already know
boozy the clown kick in the door wave
into 4 4
not feeling well but he with us right
now you know say haddock real quickly
say what's up to the people
what's going on
don't look under the weather
[Music]
appreciate you brother appreciate you
you already know yeah we supposed to
have a good one we got a good one so uh
you already know mama micah will be
pulling up hopefully get her in here and
acclimate it to the realm
last day of media fam stand up you
already know saw we got but we may have
solved unlimited time he was definitely
missed last week so anytime we could get
with him we would appreciate and you
already know the king will have a lot to
say on certain topics imax what up
what's going on everybody share this out
[ __ ] is live share this live tell your
friends hit the like what's that stuff
all the youtubers say how we got to do
it
[ __ ] you guys enjoyed the the podcast
man hit that like button hit that
subscribe for weekly podcast hit the
notification bell tell your tell your
friend tell a friend
no don't hit the notification bell man
sometimes i don't want you guys know
what i'm oh my gosh
what up retro nerd what up kool-aid what
up walter white what's going on
premature procrastinator king for the
ball stay for the heat oh yeah you're
gonna get the balls in a minute you'll
get the balls of the dollar oranges
what's up pixel big g what's going on
lucious augustus the lord of discord my
man always with the good questions also
on lsm i see y'all probably tell
everybody what's up where y'all at it's
what a clock oh i know what it is that
football playoffs that's supposed to be
with the lord i was having on two tvs
one with the lawyers and one watching
the playoffs
anyway we will be back
one monitor i don't get it
supposed to have his attic have friday
night football there's playoffs i
thought it was over what's going on i
was light play-offs baby play-offs
jailback said feel better lord addict
no doubt no doubt lola always can't wait
to hit kickstake on that playstation 4
director's cut
no doubt yeah gonna have a lot to say
anyway we will be back i'm gonna give
you all the bars you got one of them and
we will try to get mama micah it talk to
you soon
what up
[Music]
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but coming to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we
[Music]
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boil you ain't gotta say
it i'm embarrassed for you i always been
a nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell an uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
that's
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they're really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is the yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my
[Music]
you ain't got to say it i'm embarrassed
for you always been a nerd never been a
loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
her uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast
right now as we speak and uh i guess i'm
here to keep you entertained until it's
time to get this show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beating they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting
um
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say i'm better
than money because you can bank on me
being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beating they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people
[Music]
you could say that i'm very spoiled but
i'm gonna be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boy you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable this is that
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
[Music]
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got it
[Music]
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boil you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say i'm better
than money because you can bank on me
being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
when i'm in the range i was the hardest
to start regardless back we were
messaging people on aim
[Music]
i'm very spoiled for them to be your dog
thing very loyal but i ain't gonna hold
you i ain't here to boy you you ain't
gotta say it i'm embarrassed for you
i've always been a nerd never been a
loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
her uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look you gotta mess up and turn me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people on
aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
embarrassed for you i've always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with the gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
that's
[Music]
i'ma just chill and watch the snacks in
the attic i wanted to chill with the
pack and be like a young wolf but then
they would mistake me for attic if i can
imagine this cooler give you some advice
and invite your girl to your squadron
cause if you don't give her that option
you're gonna be single player like siren
you're gonna get tossed in the bushes by
king david royalty not a pretender
detrimental to an elemental what's an
avatar to a knee bender i gotta be me
though i know it's my destiny word to
cognito who cares if you fly if you
steal a mosquito you swear you ain't
something but really
you like to collect stuff and that's
cool but i got bad news even if you
really was that you can never still be
the king of the statues since the
juvenile i've been cursed with a curse
to be musical and if you hate it we'll
meet in the crucible wasn't it nothing
it's cool and it's beautiful we let you
know that your dreams are pursuable
whatever you want to do then is doable
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a lord's day
[Music]
all right all right here ye hear ye and
we are live
welcome to the iron lords podcast llc
and also live on lordsofgaming.net
episode number 240 that's another
glorious sunday we're back at the round
table on the lord's day i'm extremely
excited about our special guest and
we've got xbox series x and s sales
records
stalker 2 delay
xbox 2022 lineup and hitman 3 to game
pass and vr to discuss so we're going to
get right into it
i want to introduce a lady whose
infectious positivity and undeniable
passion for nerd culture truly resonates
within the gaming community
whether it be our detailed unboxings or
informative takes on jrpgs all done with
that trademark smile
introducing the creating host of the
mama micah youtube channel and first
lady plus coordinator of last stand
media
the lady of dragon ball z and hockey
proud mama to russian travel
and one half of gaming's most awesome
power couple in the realm
live from virginia by way of western
massachusetts and making her debut into
the realm of the lords
my girl lady mama micah how we doing sis
i'm good thank you that was quite the
intro you are a lady and lord in your
realm it's only right that we show you
the proper respect here in the room how
you doing what's been going on and what
you've been playing
uh so things are good we're getting snow
right now which makes me feel right at
home since like you said from western
massachusetts so i'm enjoying it
currently playing i've been playing
persona 5 strikers
hades and also started the pathless on
ps5 this week
the one with the ninja with the girl
with the um yes with that
yes the ball yes a lot of running
mechanics yes yes yes nice nice that's
cool that's cool so we got a little snow
going yeah we're supposed to get hit a
little bit later on for us so i know you
you're in your element
i've already been hit
i've already been hit well you already
what you got what you got
it's about like five inches of snow
outside right now over there
[Laughter]
you're ridiculous
anyway and you already know we got the
four horsemen of gaming those original
laws at a roundtable table with some uh
time sensitive because we got respect
mama michaels and solves time and
limited availability
the difficult game conqueror lord of his
own world and the how of the young wolf
my man lord addict how you doing sir
doing pretty good i just came back from
that game past airport had to direct the
people straight to the runway
you do got the jacket
you know you know uh my little flaps it
was it was it was his picture king yeah
glad you kept making sure what
can you comment on what you've been
playing no
unfortunately there is something that
says i cannot call you
yes i never understood those type of
things but like i get it but like part
of me is like yo xbox live is like
literally
like ratting what i'm playing so it's
like why can't
xbox live was clearly snitching on what
you were involved with but uh we can't
comment on it because the lord just
screenshot them and put it up
[Laughter]
and don't tag me that's my
and of course we have our most technical
gaming lord
the solo game who lives with a single
player selfish experience and also the
sastradamus
the lord of clarity and lord patreon of
the iron bank my man sorely missed last
week lord sovereign how are you doing
sir what's up guys uh happy new year
almost
look i'm sorry you you missed the
podcast you missed the podcast dude you
just keep it moving yo just come back a
week later and say happy happy new year
damn they come back
the podcast that i listened to last week
and you all sorely missed me so thank
you
[Music]
last week it could not be avoided as a
um
shout out to fedex and their theme
so okay
we'll leave that in the bushes right now
yeah i need that straight in the back
yeah shout out to y'all um to my
brothers for halloween i love the new
tragedy stuff that you can track
everything how it's going down so when
it says delivered you like what and you
can run downstairs and catch them well
that's the thing i rerouted mine because
i wasn't gonna be home so i said i'm
going to reroute it obviously it's a
public delivery drop-off space shouldn't
be an issue so i don't think the issue
was there the issue was in route um
because after this happened to me i'm
like hey let me let me just go on google
and see you know if there's a real
problem with fedex yeah that's a there's
a real problem with fedex like
if something like that happened to me
i'd be using that google maps fight was
that fedex
had a little dude with his package just
running around
because i was like it happened right i
went to work early in the morning i came
back i picked it up i'm like okay i'm
gonna go pick up my phone connect it go
up and do the show right when i go get
the when i go get the package i'm like
because it was it was the phone plus
they sent me like a whole like a like uh
what's it called the the next the ghoul
nest and stuff like that was a whole
package
so i'm like this is kind of like
and i go in there and i see the pixel 6
pro box i opened the box up they left me
the instructions
and
okay so they actually opened your
package they opened the package removed
your phone removed my phone removed
from the nerds
gave me the innards and then they what
they did they taped the outer package
was such that you could open it without
breaking it so all they did was put some
tape over it to show like if they
probably had that's like one little
piece of tape or whatever
so they covered it and i'm like okay i
didn't seem like you know they they're
they're reinforcing it and whatever i go
in there
and it was just yeah it's
a supreme opportunist yes
this just looks like a google phone
anyway so that was that um
so over the break i did just i still
haven't finished halo infinite but
that's the only thing i played okay
that game play
yes chef kiss video tell me can i can
actual question because
you know i get attacked
i get attacked by these twitter people
you
i said this is the best
halo and i'm talking about in terms of
gameplay and feel
yes
halo
no i think i think that's true i mean
okay in terms of uh in terms of the
the same thing i said about the open
world same thing i said about the open
world before the game came out before
the game came up okay
oh my yo give this a chance please get
this hold on i hate the interruption but
there's a lot the super chats are coming
in hot and me i'm i'm copying and
pasting right now so let me see you want
me to read the last one read the letters
right
brother
way to inaugurate me for 2022 let me
play with your joystick
five dollar super chat
saab i missed you cog and addict just
can't put it down like you do
pause a big big part you gotta fail you
were missed
shout out shout out to let me play with
your joystick returning to the realm
just for solve absolutely
yeah so real quick yeah um
i agree with that sentiment about it
being the best it
they still have some of that open world
stuff that issues that all open world
games have where you you
after a while you start repeating stuff
yeah but the way you navigate that game
yeah the
the uh what you're called the grapple
shot is absolutely game changing
game changing um
every engagement it makes that sandbox
feel more alive so yes it does have the
issues that all open world games have
but that gameplay and that sandbox
applied to that open world
yeah i had somebody attack me and i'm
telling him
there's absolutely no way
that
any halo that you pick up
compared to the way this spartan moves
this one ton character yeah is not as
agile as this spartan here
and you feel that agility but then when
you're going up against the brutes
they feel lumpersome and cumbersome yeah
so you have that agility to move in and
out of the way i just felt it was
how they showed each character's
movements and how they depicted it it
was perfect for me
shout out to the people in pvp that
still don't understand what the
grappling hook is sword you run you
don't charge at me yeah yeah we'll get
to that
anyway yeah so as you can tell i'm uh at
an undisclosed location
i know right
we will keep it pushing and you'll get
the super chat after king or yeah
no doubt and of course we have the
incredible hulk of this aka the access
gamer oh
the prophet of xbox swami king of the
statues who demands nothing less than
that premium experience it is the leader
of the fraud alert movement
beloved lord king how are we doing sir
i'm doing incredible all right so game
pass dropped some games this week and i
know you guys is mad but i got game pass
and i know you dry over there so let me
tell you what's going on over here wait
whoa it's dry over wear sir they know
they dry they know they're ashy oh my
god
i have the lotion for you
i have the lotion for you
and this is the problem see somebody
said oh y'all an xbox podcast i said i
am the only xbox dude over there what
are you talking about and then at the
same time i also have my playstation you
just mad because i don't rep how you
want me to win
anyway
so
anna karis
it was the hardest five minutes of my
life that i had to suffer through this
game it was the quickest delay
you have to play it uh don't you have to
play it uh co-op though i did okay i had
three other dudes with me having the
same miserable time that i was having
wow
it's goodbye it's goodbye i do not want
to try thank you i do appreciate your
effort
no it is absolutely not anything that i
want to do
so right now
i i'm ashamed of this oh
oh oh what you do um i brought the
season past the fortnight wow
that's that's family though that's
except that that's yeah that's me and my
son
but check this out check this out this
is where i got to come clean oh this is
where i got him killed already what
alert okay
this is red he doesn't want to swear i
got to come clean
what happened he wasn't on and i was
playing
oh
wow i found myself you found you fell
down the rabbit hole yo i found myself
grinding by myself pause
all right so our iron lord's podcast
we're looking for a new lord
i got i got a victory royals i got three
of them i got addicted wow
so i'm sitting there
and i'm playing and my girl walking past
and i'm like move move
and it's just me and this one dude and i
don't know how to build properly so i'm
like if this guy stopped building i'm in
trouble
i'm hiding behind the tree
i got a flare gun
i said this dude don't know what i got
in my pocket i can't so i shot at him
one time with my scout rifle pop-pop
yeah and i hit right in the bushes so i
heard him with a little spider-man webs
i said there you go baby you fell for
the trap
he came right over i shot him right in
his face with that flicker
i lit him up with that shotgun i ran
away from my victory royale i'm gonna
tell you right now
uh-oh this is this is where i said
i hate y'all more for what you did to
pub g yeah they killed your pup g man
they did yes sir it is a highly
addictive
game and every day they have different
stuff to get your money yeah and they
don't stop trying to get your cash lock
it beautiful
cash grab it's insane it says say
something let's get the super chats
quick if we can let's go cool let me
kill let me roll back for a moment oh
actually there was the last one of last
year that came in right after we went
off air yes please so i'll read that
from splendiferous absolutely super chat
sob cradles ain't coming out next year
okay we'll see we'll see all right then
we got up we got doovey member for 14
months thank you sir we out here one of
the best parts of the weekend ready to
see king hit sony with that fatality
okay
then we have senwa's dad five dollar
super jack
listen man we don't want middle ground
cog today king all by all means decimate
the playstation community god bless you
why we gotta decimate
why they don't want me though
they don't want any of this they only
want king smoke magic stuff
also good morning lords of cali good
morning to you sir thank you for waking
up early and joining us
we got [ __ ] j five dollar speech good
morning lords and mama micah welcome
back slop thank you sir
appreciate that then we have j i got
damn i want to copy this three times
tauzuichi
10 super chat what's up lords and lady
mama micah saab welcome back these guys
needed your help seeing that car can't
host and take care of super chats all
love ronin aka shogun [ __ ] wow
that's how you do vital okay
[Laughter]
i apologize for allowing them to mangle
super
then we got big cloud gaming the homie
member for 11 months salute to my
brothers of the realm keep grinding and
keep striving for greatness you as well
my little brother had a fantastic uh
kate yeager interview big cloud oh yes
yes yeah this is doing fantastic
then we have poor eyes malone with the
five dollar super chat what's up lord
shout out to mama micah i can tell king
coming with the jokes today he has on
his eddie murphy red leather yo she said
he got the delirious
hilarious yo
kid you gotta answer oh you need to
smile he's fine no no no i'm i'm i
understand
and i'm here to
deliver continue there we go hustle and
motivate the homie
shout out to him oh
dear he just oh he just let's put the
crust in the chat it's just upgraded to
lord brown thank you sir
what happened
yes sir then we got rrd with the two
dollars we chat shout out father [ __ ] yo
that's the inside joke yeah they're
killing me with that luca thing shout
out to lady lucas she had a picture of
me he's like oh he's your daughter i'm
like damn
to be dirty
[Laughter]
the lord of super chats is back salute
to the lords on this lord's say thank
you sir y'all a little too excited to
hear back
then we got suicide kings member for 15
months thank you so much sir
king david saying twitter peeps are
attacking me as he stands over some poor
twitter fool holding her back
there we have kelly may five dollars for
chat mama micah's hair really out here
showing the panel up get out the jurgens
for these playstation dudes could get
there i mean
there isn't much hair to show up but
yeah
she's killing us
then we got slow mo back slap five
dollars in the chat
shout out to the lords especially the
lord of leakes lord ins insider nido
he messed with iraq is a defining duke
yeah something was stopped went viral
speculation
yeah yeah that's me and matty that was
you man what's funny is i i was at a
discord i was like man wouldn't matty do
this
it was both of us it was supposed to be
amazing
it says not telling you what you want to
hear but leaking what you need to do
slow it's all it's all dps stop it
okay hold on let me roll back a little
bit because we have a few
okay hey start yeah once we start then
we have render with the two dollar super
chat agent 47 definitely coming for
king's fit
then we have
kirovator five dollars super chat please
say something sir appreciate you please
please
then we have lucious augustus five
dollars chat
shout out to the lords it's great to see
xbox doing well the past holiday season
but i'm looking forward to 2022 and no
matter what game pass got me okay
all right one last one shout out to
david hot right got that black mob he
got the actually got the 10k coffee mum
he said he couldn't pass up an
opportunity to commemorate today's show
with lady micah salute lords and lady on
the lord's day hello david hot right
that's what's up so as we continue you
know we still got it i'm sorry okay keep
in mind uh chad those 10k products are
leaving yes
if you want to pick it up i would
suggest pick them up today yes 10k
shirts and all that merch cops will be
leaving about the gold limited edition
and of course we have the gaming ninja
himself the shinobi lord cognito spread
that realist in the roman iop not
telling what you want to hear but what
you need to hear shout out to defining
duke again with mr maddie plays had a
good show talking that stalker to delay
also e3 stuff and more
also check out the lsn patreon we got an
amazing show with cobra commander
himself mr colin moriarty and myself and
maddie talking about tencent very
powerful discussion very honest
discussion check that out for that's an
exclusive up on the patreon um shout out
to the last word with ibontis and ty guy
travis we had a good guess from nasa
lady lucia talking about that witch
queen the new trailer the old generation
stuff there's a little controversy going
on there for me as far as gaming's i've
been back audacity this week for a
little bit shout out to uh dj orson and
chad he was those guys are helping me
out i got the dungeon completely got my
gala on catalyst king so i'm very happy
i'm getting all my
i'm not your friend anyway because you
have the uh the vex so yeah oh you ain't
getting
you you really can have it
you can really oh sorry i apologize okay
anyway moving on um yeah so that was
that i've been doing that and then um
halo 5 multiplayer just been rocking out
but uh one last super chat's off
oh that vr's crazy it's been uh dmail
but i get a chance the plus was to play
yesterday it's been a busy week blame mr
maddie plays he got me working we're
doing a lot of shows so i couldn't play
as much uh vr as i wanted to play but i
wanted to play that contractor yeah we
got to get contractors we got to get
debut on so get that got the rifts out
you already know grab up acg
once again five dollar super chat this
is the first time i'm catching you guys
live and giving a super chat ohayo
goshamaisu
taking a break from the game past
goodness that is dragon age inquisition
with auto hdr and fps boost looking and
playing gorgeous wow i might have to go
back to that i didn't realize i had both
then we got flame five dollar super chat
good afternoon round been a while so
i'll keep it brief playing god of war on
pc is a great time have a great show oh
you're not playing the downgraded
version
although flame did say he was not
feeling the the dad's story he was not
about the dadness
how how you feel about that xbox
controller
moving along
getting messy so now we got all the
business taken care of and our guest has
been very patient with us
we gotta foolishness with our
foolishness
we gotta focus on mama micah her journey
into video game creation and of course
what led her to become the coordinator
for last stand media but lady michael
let's start from the very beginning what
were some of the first video game
systems you had and what got you into
gaming
oh sure so growing up we didn't have a
lot of money when i was a kid so i was
primarily playing games at my friend's
houses so i had one friend with an n64
and we'd always play mario kart i had a
different friend that had her dad at a
ps2 so we'd play the crash bandicoot in
spyro and i looked forward to that so
much when i was a kid i loved you know
playing games with them
when i was like 10 i ended up getting a
game boy advance which i still have it
still works um
and i only ever got three games for it
though so i have a lot of games i still
want to go back and play on it i've been
slowly buying some of the ones i missed
out on
but that was really what got it started
was going to friends houses and playing
oh it's it was the blue game boy advance
sp the see-through
what was the three games though what was
the three games you had or for the uh
i had kim possible two okay i had virtua
tennis and i had finding nemo
different yeah what what did you
graduate to or what was kind of like
then the first
concert or did you still like you still
kind of you playing off your friend's
consoles and stuff for for a while what
was the next transition as far as
consoles so
yeah i played you know my sister and i
would play a lot of computer games
together so my mom bought us like road
rash because she really wasn't paying
attention to what she was buying and she
was a cool racing game you'll like it i
like this motorcycle racing games and
beating people and running awesome
the music is good music is good
she bought us that she bought us driver
at one point for pcc because she was
like it's another racing game you'll
love it
he's like mike have you heard of this
game called grand theft auto
it's a racing game you might want to
race the game you gotta love it here you
go
so we were super into stuff like that um
in high school i ended up being friends
with kids that had like xboxes and
that's when i started playing 360. and i
fell in love with it um the first game i
really played
like red dead redemption
let's hear about that red dead
redemption love why what what drew you
to that game because of
loves this game
oh i love westerns when i was a kid my
mom and i always watched westerns
together like gunsmoke and bonanza and
all these shows
so i just loved westerns and i had no
idea there was a western video game and
growing up in a very rural area hunting
is really big where i lived so it was
cool to have this game that it's got
hunting it's got horses and all this
stuff i loved it and it's still my
all-time favorite game i absolutely
adored it and that got me playing
shooters as well because from there i
played gears 3.
i love the gears series the multiplayer
especially
but red dead really kicked it off for me
um that is awesome like can't go wrong
uh solve do you approve you already
comments uh uh 100 percent approved
he's on the right side of history
for the red dead community uh the the
the not say controversy but
one or two which one do you prefer mama
micah
so i'll say the first one's always going
to be my favorite because i love john
marston that character is probably my
all-time favorite character across all
media books movies games i just loved
that character and story red dead 2 is
amazing and i was completely thrilled
that there was a character named micah
in it it just felt perfect to me because
it's my all-time favorite game
uh and he was a bad guy which is great
because i love villains
but definitely the first one nice nice
cool cool so you're going from there you
stay in the 360 era and you said gears
any other standouts from the 360 era
that really meant a lot to you
honestly i just loved anything that was
couch co-op
i loved borderlands especially the first
one i didn't play co-op because it only
had vertical split screen which we hated
but my roommate and i played you know
the rest of the borderlands games
together in co-op i really loved any
couch co-op games um that was a real fun
part you know having roommates in
college years and things and being able
to play games with them especially
shooters
or even you know call of duty always
playing like zombies modes together or
smack ops and like modern warfare three
um those were always my favorite
experiences to sharing it with a friend
yeah that makes sense at 360
you know with the control it was kind of
built for that first person you know
kind of feel and let's be honest king
right they you know when modern war i
mean obviously halo is what halo is but
360 then kind of introduce a lot of
gamers to call of duty and the modern
call of duty
when it first came oh
and they had the smoke effect
uh yeah you know because like when you
when you came through the city and you
know the tanks was coming through and
they shot the smoke canisters
we saw the smoke
like when we saw the fur on king kong
and then
oh yeah
yeah
360 was powerful i can't i can't relate
on the call of duty thing i was a call
of duty hater from birth from the
beginning
i think besides besides getting a pc to
play half-life and and doom 3
it was that call of duty because when
you saw that first call of duty like oh
my god because we were playing medal of
honor and medallion was cool but it
wasn't that wasn't that you know what it
was i didn't realize what 60 phrase was
i just knew this felt
different different than halo at the
time and be honest you know it took a
lot of people off halo during that
during that period but
i had a different experience when i
first saw call of duty i said can we
turn this off oh my god
what was it first was it the world war
ii like the first one or was it modern
warfare 4 it was the first one
um
call of duty it's one the one where
zombies first came in that was world
that worked
award
yeah that was okay yes i can understand
but so back to my bike um the emotional
mention gears right and i know
that seems to resonate right and it kind
of fits the you know you got your co-op
aspect you know what
else was it about gears i know that's
one of your franchise you're also very
passionate about
yeah uh the characters for sure my
favorite character was always damon
baird um he's just a real you know smart
alex sarcastic guy
funny he has the best lines i always
play as him in multiplayer um i loved
the horde mode oh
it was just
it was just incredible to play that the
first one i played was gears three and
then we went back and played you know
the first and second one and i just
adored it and the multiplayer was really
intimidating because it's it's much
slower paced than call of duty but once
you get into it it's really my favorite
multiplayer across any games that i've
played really it's very highly skill
based like if you uh are really skilled
uh you have an advantage over
[Music]
do you mean the spider-man wall hoppers
yeah yeah the shotgun tuck and roll boy
yeah
they get you are they on your team oh
you love them yeah they pick you up all
the time i wanted to shout out with that
because you know
few people mention horde bold from gears
and they introduced that and i really
appreciate it because at the time mike
if we remember like wasn't it five
players and i always thought that was so
cool because most games the max was
usually four and i just love setting up
the defenses your little you know and
the waves come it would just play hours
and hours and it was just a ton of fun
yeah
like the
the only thing i saw call of duty for
was like a zombies game like it didn't
have a multiplayer campaign it literally
just had zombies so like i guess like
like uh you know the mansion from black
ops like i prefer to play those horde
modes over anything else because i
didn't
it's not that i didn't like the gears
horde mode it's just like
i didn't really ha like i jumped into
the gears franchise way late so by then
it was just like it was just outdated
it's out there no fair enough fair
enough see got the 360 doing that so
then was the next transition
to the xbox one did you go playstation 3
playstation 4 what was your next
transition as far as console was
sure so uh we had a ps3 i didn't play it
very much though i've never been much of
a playstation gamer i usually play on
xbox and nintendo
or i really played the vita a lot oh
salute to defeat uh salute to you
if i have a taste
that was sort of the exception
it's funny i was gonna i wasn't sure how
if she wasn't being a player because you
know colin loves vita right so i was
like has he tried to borg her into be
the island
standouts
um geez i play a lot of visual novels on
vita uh i like persona 4 golden a lot um
but
yeah i i hate a lot of the games that
that colin really likes like
i hated that
look it look different everyone has
their own taste everyone has their own
thing that's that's really cool so you
got that so not too much ps3 obviously
so then i'm assuming you stay into the
xbox one error you go you move into the
xbox one era after the 360 then is that
correct
definitely yeah um and not not to say
that we didn't also get the playstations
we you know we ended up like pooling our
money together to get the special
edition so i had like the batman like
arkham ps4 and we got the spider-man one
as well because i i'm a big collector of
you know figures and things like that
physical games still but yeah xbox has
always been the primary system for me
it's where i play all the third-party
games mostly because the controller is
my favorite i love the offset you know
what you know what you're welcome here
you know
i had i had i had a little questions but
right now you have answered everything
and i think you're on to something oh my
god let's go don't worry he'll find out
more questions don't worry he'll find
out more
this is great i just love uh you know
this is the king is definitely happy
with uh
control of choice is a fantastic yes yes
i can't
anyway so do the expo no i gotta ask you
[ __ ] some fun xbox one questions because
me and maddie have something played
eventually what brought like a
retrospective but um were you a connect
lady
yes oh i loved connect
let's talk about it real quick briefly
any particular um
moments or or standouts that you know
because it was i'd say it's polarizing
some people you know didn't like it then
you got the whole it's spying on you
song remember
yeah you know that
of thing but like was it something you
had specific games the fitness or like
the dance stuff or anything you could
remember would connect that you uh that
really appealed to you
yeah so back in the day i was a big
achievement hunter and so i had game fly
and i would rent any easy game to try
and get as many points as possible so i
would get all the connect games that
were just they were really fun they were
genuinely fun but they were all the
children's games and so connect the
moles was a favorite where you get to
raise your own little pet
they had some really fun dance games
that i enjoyed i wish that some of them
were better
you know like the dragon ball z game
that was just terrible
i always hoped for more from connect
because i i enjoyed using it i loved the
idea of it but they just really didn't
deliver with enough quality experiences
yeah like i said the tech was really
advanced for its time and it's a shame
because yeah the experiences just
weren't all the way up to snuff you know
but uh i i wanted to sidetrack with the
xbox one again in reference to two
specific things one obviously you're a
big fan of hockey right so i want to
know about any hockey games did you when
you were ea nhl kind of kind of girl oh
and then the second thing was i found
out me and you
share a very particular love of an xbox
one game that nobody was actually
multi-player but nobody really talks
about and i rave for this game king saw
everyone knows and i never heard anyone
else raving for it this is the police we
got to talk about that
let's go so hockey first and then this
is the police
yeah i mean i'm a huge hockey fan
wearing a bruins shirt right now um
but i don't really play many sports
games
when i was a kid i would play the i
can't remember which game it was it
wasn't like a football game and you'd
light on fire when you're like doing it
i
i loved games like that that were more
arcadey and fun
i don't get into the simulation type
games as much um for me it's just not as
fun as watching sports because i'm a big
football fan too
but i do like seeing what they do with
the hockey games each year i keep an eye
on them because i like seeing you know
how they update them they just look
better and better every year and we got
to talk about that this is the police i
was very pleased to see you you had like
an xbox one
kind of you know collection video right
and solve is awesome she's going through
so i'm like wait a minute i don't
accompany this game i was shocked like
tell the world why this game because i
love it i'm very passionate tell it why
that gauge like it really resonated with
you
oh sure i mean no spoilers at all but it
is just
surprisingly
the depth of the story was just shocking
i you you open up this experience and it
just seems like a quaint little
management game
and then suddenly it just descends into
madness
it's incredible the story is phenomenal
you have an amazing soundtrack of some
really fantastic retro music voice
acting and then it's it's this really
great management game and it's i i
absolutely adored it i have not played
the second one yet i do own it but i
have not played the second yeah
second one this is this don't want the
corrupt
police
voiced by like the actor that player i
think duke nukem
and
yeah it's hilarious like he's got to
deal with managing the police and you've
got this corrupt mob influence going on
so you got moral choices there's gray
area and then like uh micah said like
you the management aspect of you know
there's a lot of crime events that's
happening that you have to manage the
amount of cops you send and it's it's
it's a lot of push-pull if you don't
send enough and you send the right type
of people this is the police too expands
even further on it i still feel the
first one is better but the two tries to
add like an x-com strategy technical
layer to it horrible
yeah it wasn't me and the attic
agreement it was so bad like i i played
a couple of those battles and i'm like
yeah this can delete it
it just they try to act like a game play
i think they would have been fine with
to get up with the management layer how
it used to be in one but i'm glad you
mentioned that but uh i want to move
forward because obviously we got a lot
to talk about game stuff but i want to
keep moving with other things too um
content creation because
one thing about you that i love is you
know you got these amazing unboxings you
kind of do a lot of different things in
geek and their culture pop culture which
is really cool but like what inspires
you to kind of put yourself out there
and say hey i'm going to be a content
creator i want to have youtube channel
like what was that
oh so back in the day i was just a huge
fan of different channels like ign and
rooster teeth what was the other one
though
machinima i was just a huge fan of all
those channels and i wanted to pretend
that i worked there so i would just in
between classes this is when i was in
college that i started the channel i
would just make my little videos and
pretend that i got to work at ign
because i was just such a huge fan back
in the day and that was my little way to
just sort of have fun talk to people
about games i don't have too many
friends in real life that are still
gaming most of my friends have moved on
from it so building this little
community where in the comments we get
to talk about games you know in the
facebook group and on twitter and things
like that it's connected me with so many
people now that i get to talk about
games and the figures collectibles that
i buy when in real life i don't really
have that same outlet
i hear you king you want to comment on
those collectibles you're oh no because
i i know she's going to probably say um
pvcs black plastic vinyl collectibles uh
like from i i may assume but i could be
wrong i think i see dragon ball z in the
background yes but yeah you're a huge
jack of all these man you think how did
you mistake gold
oh oh we gonna get to that segment
[Laughter]
and i see
one in there too
please looks like hercule that might be
herku i don't know please please don't
mind attic he's just rude um
but um
what i was going to ask you uh because i
used to collect
the
video game pvcs like the um
ultimate uh packages what like with
titanfall
or the halos and stuff like that did you
uh pursue any of those collectibles
um i don't get too many of the like
super collectors editions of games i'll
pick up i'm almost always trying to get
the steel books i love collecting steel
books um for like yakuza 6 i got the
edition that came with like the drinking
glasses and everything but too many
times for me the game comes with a
figure for like a new character like
gears 4 collector's edition came with
the jd statue right and i'm like i don't
know if i'm going to like this dude i
did not
could be committed to you yeah i feel
like i feel like it should have been
like she was a way better character than
jd so it's it's just it's a lot of money
to drop on a character that you don't
know if you're gonna like
so for the most part i don't pick up too
many of like the super special editions
of games but i often do get a
collector's edition of some kind uh for
most games if they have one available
that's like a mid-tier option i'll get
that okay okay that's cool now we
consistently we might as well just
transition right into it because attic
was piping up so um you know one thing
that you clearly i clearly respected you
you have an immense passion for pop
culture is anime so clearly the attic
segment so i need to know how this got
started and then why you so hardcore
with dragon ball z
oh sure so that just started with my
roommate in college one day decided they
were going to watch dragon ball z all
over again okay and we just watched it
together at first i wasn't going to
watch it i thought it was weird and then
i just kept hearing screaming from the
other room and i was like why are they
yelling all the time like what's
happening these men are just constantly
yelling like 40 of the show every
episode
[Laughter]
so i just i ended up watching it and i
fell in love with vegeta he's my
favorite character because i just love
villains and villains in any media are
always my favorite characters okay so
from dragon ball z then we end up
watching dragon ball we watched all the
movies together um and then from there
we just you know got a funimation
account and just kept watching more
shows that's what some addict do we
approve vegeta do we approve
yeah vegeta is cool
vegeta is like one of those characters
where like the writer don't know what he
wants to do with them like okay you're
gonna be you're gonna be a good solid
character this year the next year but
like nah i'm good
like like
next year is your year vegeta
so it was like edgy came back because
like for a person who's a non anime
person like you know not dragon ball
person like
what
what besides the yelling and the over
the top and clearly vegeta like what was
also the draw i'm trying to get also the
draw what else drew you in about the
series
probably the tension i would say yeah
there's there's a lot of suspense
tension looks very violent and as a big
i'm also a big wrestling fan
so i'm a big wwe fan let's go and so if
you like wrestling and then you start
watching dragon ball z it's kind of like
that oh it just really pulls the same
strings like that i got you that's
what's up that's what's up any other uh
anime besides uh dragon ball like give
me some of your like your top ones
oh sure um naruto for sure
is another one i watch a lot of like
one-off like comedy shows uh like like
kjoe is really funny like sports anime
um it's just a lot of things like that i
just i like the cooking ones that are
like fun
did you like um
what was that dr stone have you ever
tried that i have not
that's a good idea what about the kenji
intensity
i don't know that's insane yeah okay
okay
netflix um
you know listen
got me on
well he reignited it because you know i
started with dragon ball z back in the
days and i stopped and he got me with no
r2
and
that was like the craziest eight months
of your life
i believe this show is so long it's
unreal it i lost my soul watching this
stuff because i didn't know how long it
was
and i just started and then i just kept
going and now i'm reading subtitles
because you know i had the english dubs
that was pretty cool so just out of
curiosity king because i didn't get this
from you how did you feel when you
watched the original naruto and you
found out yo that's another whole show
listen um i'm not gonna lie once you
start down that rabbit hole then you go
all the way in and i stay far away from
dragon ball z because i started with it
and because i had saw this one character
uh and he's the little cat the little
egyptian cat and um
you know what i'm talking about
and he like he he's like the destroyer
of worlds so he shows up and he just
wants to have uh coffee and cake on your
planet and when he has coffee and cake
on your planet he kills everybody after
eating coffee and cake on your plate
literally he
he he wanted ice cream and it was gone
and he threatened to blow up the whole
world over it oh my god
question though stopped i had to stop
have you tried like the new um
ones like attack on titan or demon
slayer or anything like that
because people like to try like in anime
people call like the most popular
enemies that's ever existed bleach one
piece and naruto they call them like the
big three those are the ones that
elevated anime to mainstream have you
tried like the newer ones like the demon
slayer attack on titan yeah eddie those
intros to your mama
they interest me for sure i have not
watched them yet i haven't had my
funimation subscription since i moved so
i gotta get that going again i don't i
don't watch as much tv as i used to
gotcha so
i got you that fandom if you have a game
pad subscription
[Music]
you got a crunchyroll rolled up into
attack that's ultimate i i will say that
like as far as like anime attack on
titan it's like probably the best anime
i've ever watched
high praise from addict that is high
praise you already know absolute salute
and i i caught the wrestling i just
wanted real quick i don't go too deep
into that hope rabbit hole some of the
favorite wrestlers that you you liked or
from wwe fairly curious oh sure we're
old school wrestlers we're talking like
jake the snake roberts ravishing rick
what i'd like to have right now
sorry
for newer wrestlers definitely uh like
sheamus i was a big randy orton fan for
a long time um i haven't watched it
recently i kind of fell off with
wrestling but also bobby lashley big
shout out to him i met him at a show
i've assigned you know photo of him
she was getting in
any wrestling games at all not not too
much
i am just terrible at them but but there
was a really fun one on wii i think it
was wwe all-stars it was really cartoony
yes and just over the top and i loved
that nice just hysterical awesome
awesome like tremendous history there
tremendous anime history loving the the
versatility of the nerd and the geek
culture kind of found out
that dude
he's the only person because i have a
friend that i grew up with that claimed
i'm going to be wrestling our girl that
dude working at like a like uh he he he
controls where all the the people
deliver stuff why are you saying well i
like that no i'm not showing him he's
doing good for himself
all i'm saying is like
baron i have seen that man struggle for
years and now i see him on tv play uh on
w uh whatever the awe or what whatever
it is like
i just gotta give a shout out to mike
for loving heels when you're smoking
when you're small yes yeah when you're
young you don't tend to gravitate to the
heels just like i hate this person if i
see you in front of me tell you
and you know like when you talk about i
love ravishing rick rule
in retrospect you're as an adult you
like they were the best because again
any the
any here hero worth assault is only as
good as
his villains right yeah and 80s heels oh
hold on there was some of the most
amazing hills ever and those two
those two were the dudes that you saw
them come out and be like i can't hate
but i despise him yeah like when they
they threw my man ultimate warrior in
the coffin
i was terrorized i thought he was dead
for real like
i was a such a warrior fan so when i saw
that i was like he can't he can't
breathe in there
yo king always devastated that [ __ ] i
would just i would just love for me
ravishing rickroot because
he could he could back it up with his
in-ring skills everywhere he went he
just he insulted everybody
he was absolutely filled but
i gotta say this if you listen to
everything that she said she told you
all this stuff really happened when she
started hanging out with the xbox dude
[Laughter]
they had a problem you're a bad
influencer
literally she said after that it's like
vegeta then his micah and he's a bad guy
yeah and red devil redemption too so i
like him
he's got to turn everything into xbox
you're right
again hey last shot i saw we got a shout
out get it okay ted dibiase was
ted dibiase was again like i mean the
heel of all hills right to me
uh r.i.p is bobby right bobby yes but
but we didn't we didn't see him wrestle
that much we mostly saw him in the
capacity of being a manager whatever but
yeah ted dibiase was a dude oh yeah came
out and and the thing is it's funny when
you start when you start listening to
behind the scenes stuff of how good he
was like kind of promoting other people
and bringing people up and you just as a
kid you're like this this dude i hate
this guy you know i got a chance to
speak to him right now did you at a
comic con oh that's what's going on then
i'm talking behind the scenes and then
just before it started man who's back
there talking i was like oh my god i
just i just want you to sign something i
have nothing for him to find
i'm sorry guys man like look like it's
about enough i gotta deal with combat
tall we really want to talk about sleep
i just listen to your anime
[Music]
no and the thing is my anime love ended
like i never why i got into the shows i
never got into dragon ball whatever but
i used to love like
old school movies like uh vampire hunter
d yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah i can't remember beyond that i
never got i never got into the shows
they evolved
time one
but i want to focus on lady mike in a
sense that you know in my opinion
obviously you got this cool channel
you're doing all the stuff you're
following everybody you know you're like
hey this is how i would be if you know
if ig you know whoever any big outlet
this is me you put yourself out there
but what i think is one of your magic
moments which one of many magic moments
is um you know
you kind of as a content creator you
sometimes don't say you get into things
with your heroes but sometimes you have
disagreements right you know one thing
obviously you being a fan of sacred
symbols and colin and stuff like that
and there was a point where you guys had
a differing viewpoint on something and
it was kind of during a period where
it's got a lot of civil unrest going on
and um one thing i thought was pretty
amazing in typical colin fashion where
you know if someone disagrees with him
something he will invite the person on
to the show so they could have some
discourse so um one thing that kind of
led to another and then you're on sega
symbols plus and it was the uh black
gaming experience show and i thought it
was very insightful and um i think
during in my opinion during that which
was very cool i think you guys realize
there's more commonalities with the
discussion than you thought so i wanted
you to us to do to take us through that
experience overall because i thought the
result was really cool of you guys
coming together on that
oh definitely i mean i was just stoked
to get to meet him in the first place i
was really intimidated that he invited
me on to do a topic like that
because the whole thing it did it
started because you know i saw something
he'd said on twitter and and i just sent
him a message just to kind of clarify
because it concerned me a bit just some
of the things that he had pointed out
and he got back to me of course he's
super nice i'd never interacted with him
in my life um i was just a fan at that
point and they ended up inviting me to
be on the show which i was really
intimidated to tackle a topic like that
i thought what have i gotten myself into
i just wanted to talk to mitchell
oh my god sensitive subject man it was
definitely yeah you could do
yeah um and so he he had a lot of really
thoughtful questions um and i i liked
being on the show it was really cool i i
didn't feel at any point like i was
being attacked or anything or like it
was an ambush you know
it was it was a really nice chill
discussion and and you're completely
right we had a ton in common and that
was also what i wanted to highlight was
that we can have disagreements with
people and still have completely civil
conversations
because there are things that we
disagreed about on the show but it was
never an argument it was never bashing
anyone
i think that's what is sorely needed on
the internet it's proof that you can
talk to people about things you
disagree on without having a fight yes
yes attic raises here get it
i feel like when it comes to calling
like because he he does have like a
little bit of an aggressive uh tone when
you know he debates you
so i feel like people feel that is like
him disrespecting it like you can have
an aggressive tone when you're talking
to someone because it's not necessarily
he's being aggressive he's just trying
to understand what you're understanding
and i feel like a lot of people take
that as disrespect it's like no you
could still try to get that perspective
from someone else and it's not
disrespectful but i feel like these days
no one wants to have those conversations
like they they they want they're more
obsessed with you seeing their view
correct it's not necessarily you seeing
their view but they want you being their
view and they don't care about cutting a
middle ground that's exactly it that's
what i thought was so beautiful about
the discussion because i listened to it
it's a very you know sensitive subject
it was during the time obviously
unfortunately you know george floyd lost
his life there was a twitter was twitter
was ugly let's be honest y'all twitter
during that period oh world was that and
micah you really resonated with me
because
what you said is something that i do
which is like look you know everyone
knows my motto i don't care about your
background politics religion sexuality
anything as long as you're a gamer i
embrace you but during that period the
reason why i don't engage in that lot on
twitter because they end up becoming
divisive things and then i don't want to
not like you anymore so you know so it's
better i just like either ignore and
just we're not going to get into that
and i focus on the gaming things that
unified but the thing that you said was
cool too because you were like you know
when you're looking at your timeline
everything that's going on and you're
like oh my god this is such a dark
practice i don't want to
eliminate some of my favorite people or
favorite friends and the fact that you
guys were able to have that discussion
which was cool you did it in the dm
which is respectful as well because
let's be honest once it go public and
everyone jumps in it chimes in throws
tomatoes has they yeah you know it gets
ugly and what's cool is the tact you
chose because you just said you know
what let's have a discussion so many
things that was said kind of bothered me
and he was like great you talk about it
and it ends up becoming this beautiful
thing that you're like wow this is
really cool you know we could come
together on something and see each
other's perspective you know kind of
thing i thought that was cool micah
yeah definitely i um the point of you
know sending the direct message to was
like you said
it was a really sensitive topic and it's
one of those i could have said something
really inflammatory had a bunch of
people behind me on my side and that
would have but i don't want to hurt
content creators that i support and
admire i want to actually talk to them i
want to actually figure out you know
what's going on it wasn't about trying
to get like twitter clout or anything
and not to mention like that's not
educating either like just flaming
someone on twitter because you don't
believe in their perspective
that's not educating and that's why so
much stuff constantly happens because
there's more
attacking
someone's perspective than educating
them on why they're wrong yeah and i
feel like it's like i said there's no
middle ground it's either one or the
other one or the other no no i saw you
about to say something
no no no oh i'm sorry okay no no i
thought it was great and again shout out
to colin as well because that's one
thing i really respect about him too
which is like like
we could disagree but he's like yo let's
have the discussion you know let let's
talk about it and and that that that's
real bad stuff from where me and king
from come from you know i mean like
let's talk about it we don't got to get
inflammatory disrespectful yeah
in the street stuff like first
my thing is
the dm that's perfect yes yeah you know
because if anything comes out of there
you you know it's a one-way uh
well two-way conversation if he doesn't
say anything it's just a one-way
conversation
only you two know this right all right
so if it got out any type of way then
you know okay well then he put it there
uh type of thing um but also
i noticed when people put stuff on front
page on twitter that means that they're
checking for the like you said twitter
clout which is a weird thing i
i really don't think it exists but it
exists in people's heads like they think
they want up to you on something
yeah i i
engage in weird stuff like what i don't
like is
i don't like
when they call each other x-bots
and ponies
and um i was going to address that
earlier in the show
uh because i noticed a lot of content
creators i just want to tell a lot of
the content creators yeah if you're not
a content creator say all the stuff that
you want to say
but as a content creator you have a lot
of people looking at you
so when you put stuff like xbots and
ponies you're perpetuating these uh
negative stereotypes right just don't
say those words you can get your point
across without saying those words yeah
and just you know stop on that part but
yeah i understand exactly what you're
saying and i appreciate you just you
know talking to the dm's yeah i agree
i mean
i'm going to say plus you know
bravo for you being able to have that
conversation because that's like a rare
trait these days like i feel like
everyone's on 10 man and no one wants to
calm down like yeah no absolutely and
and again you know you'd be surprised so
many situations that the lords
themselves have defused has been in the
dms because there's many hey man what
you said kind of rubbed me a little bit
you know let's talk about it and then
you had that understanding but the
minute it goes public if we would have
went first without inclination that
person pissed me off i'm going to go
then it gets crazy and it can't
sometimes and when people do
take that uh
the dirty road
you just gotta you know high step and
just walk yeah yeah that's them i'll be
like yo you're doing good
god bless i wish you the best success
it's just not the lane that we chose to
i want to do exactly so last question i
do have obama micah was um also counting
that vein which is uh being a female
gamer of color you know how do you feel
about the state of black representation
in the games industry as general and
then the second part as far as like
video game protagonists of color you
know do you think we're starting to see
improvements there do you think more can
be done so how do you feel on both
subjects there
oh sure so i mean starting off huge
shout out to nadine from art uncharted
4.
i loved that character she was so cool
and she had the natural hair which is a
beef i have i'll talk about it it
doesn't seem very important but when you
see black characters in games and they
always have straight hair and i know
that hair and games is still terrible
i'll fully say that hair in games still
looks really bad
and i don't blame people for not wanting
to tackle curly hair but when you see
someone do it right and they take the
care to give this woman a natural look
and i just loved her as a character for
who she was she was funny she was tough
as nails she was just cool to be around
and she was a villain which is great
then of course in
legacy you get to hang out with chloe
and it's two of them you know tag team
in the world so
i adored that and that experience
it showed me how much it does matter to
me that's something we talked about in
my discussion with colin because he was
sort of saying you know why does it
matter to have representation in games
and one of the examples i gave was that
i'm biracial my dad's white my mom's
black as a kid you never saw biracial
families on tv you saw black families
you saw white families and i never
thought anything of it until i saw it
was like an old navy commercial that
showed a biracial family
and it was the first time in my life i
saw someone on tv that looked like i did
and it did matter and that's when i
realized that
it does it does feel different to have
people in media that look like you
and so
i do think games are going in a great
direction i'm certainly not you know
someone that's like heavily pushing for
it i want it to be meaningful i don't
want this to feel forced
if you create a great game that has a
black woman in the lead you know right
in the forefront like uncharted 4. they
did an excellent job with that so yeah
absolutely so i'm happy with where games
are going um
the new call of duty that had like the
black protagonist in that he was an
excellent character he's a strong leader
he was just really fun to you know play
as and the rest of the crew as well so
i'm happy with what we have so far and
just excited to see the future you know
what else they bring us in games
absolutely totally agree and i swear i
wanted to bring that subject up because
i had i had to get you today dean uh was
it jeff or always mispronounce this
jeffrey gif
gift
sacrilege sorry
that character it definitely meant and
um yeah it's good so i was gonna add
something else after you finish it it's
it's it's weird like exactly what micah
says like you don't realize that you
want that representation until you
actively think about it not being there
because oftentimes you just again you
just you watch stuff and you don't think
about it when you're younger necessarily
if it doesn't come up as a subject and
as you get older you start seeing it and
you realize how important it is i
remember just a just a couple of weeks
ago my wife and i sat down and watched
encanto the uh
disney movie
and and then there was a whole you know
sort of meme and gift that came out of
that where a young boy was standing next
to the a character that was in the movie
on the tv and it was he was he was a
biracial kid a dark-skinned had a big
hair afro and the kid you know he saw
himself in that character in a way that
honestly i haven't really seen before
maybe uh looking at like miles morales
in the spider-man movie or something
like that but before that
i'd never really seen that
representation for it to come from
disney you know kind of like
the most evil of evil
it's it's it's excellent to see because
you know that on that level it's
something that's being overtly addressed
right you have to and i wish it didn't
have to be that way that you have to do
that but again in order to move forward
it has to be something that that you
that you make an effort to put in these
in in games and in movies and do
properly you know so
i want to defend disney right there
[Laughter]
you know why because uh my daughters
watch disney stuff and i'm i sit there
and i watch it with them so i see a lot
of our representation in it and they had
a lot of hispanic other movies as well
and i just finished watching uh luca and
you know about uh two italian uh merman
with my boys which was really good and
and and i and i thought about it while
i'm watching it with my granddaughter
um
i've never saw
and i could be wrong
a movie about italians
uh in like their homeland right right
just sort of americanized stereotypes of
italians right right so i said wow i
said this i said for some italian kid
right now
they're seeing their self
in this right here and i said this must
be so cool right now yeah and it was
just a really good i really liked the
film it made me cry yeah yeah i do cry
i cry all the time
yeah another thing i i do have to give
you the props because another thing that
i saw um i don't know if you saw this as
well king interstitially between between
movies they'll give like a little
advertisement thing and they showed a
thing where it was a sort of uh a reel
of all the old you know crazy racist
movies oh yeah and they said they said
this is our past
we know what we've done
yeah we know what we have to change in
the future like they they addressed it
in a way i never thought it would you
know again and as a young kid you watch
all these movies you love these movies
you don't see those things right until
yeah they took them off completely but
the thing about it for them to
acknowledge it that way and actually
just actually just re-show them because
a lot of times you that stuff will
disappear you never see it again but for
them to address it so directly and say
hey
we're making a concerted effort to right
this wrong was was something that i saw
i was like wow things really are
changing there really is this [ __ ] our
consumer dollars
and you're going to represent us in this
uh poor fashion then we shall not patron
your weirds it's just very simple
um and
if you do want our dollars then you're
going to have to have to represent us
accordingly yeah and like you said you
you saw
a commercial and you never thought about
it before until you saw the commercial
with a family that represented yours
yeah
wow i didn't know i needed something yes
that i didn't see and that's where the
emotional part of it hits right because
sometimes myself like why am i getting
emotional this is a simple thing why
because you don't see it so when you
finally see it you're like okay this is
me like i'm out here
i remember what playing miles morales
when i saw pastels
i lost it i lost it my wife walked in
front of the tv she was like i don't
sponsor this i'm like yup
this is
i watched the whole black panther
my kids are sitting there
and i'm crying throughout the whole
movie
because this is the first movie and i'm
i it could be something else but
and
it was just no buffoonery yeah
culture we we weren't the doorman
you know it's just
i i just felt a huge sense of pride
throughout the whole movie and i'm like
wow my kids get to grow up here now this
right here and i'm like wow i get to
experience this with them i don't know
what this means later for them but i
know what it means for me now no doubt
and um definitely want to include i want
to disclose addict on this but just your
feeling on that whole representation
thing with gaming
alex quiet
he said i am not touching that with a
20-foot boat
i i ain't gonna lie like i don't like
talking about that stuff because you
don't feel like i feel like
it doesn't matter what i say if i say
something people tell me i'm white i
need to shut up no i say something
that's why i'm not here
no just a gentleman whatever you feel
it's your feeling it's how you feel
brother don't worry it's just something
that it's going to take time you know
you
it's got to be one of those scenarios
where
i don't think a lot of people are
against it a lot of people are against
like if it's forced right like turning
their favorite characters they they grew
up with turning them to a different
ethnicity like i think it's more of that
than anything else
because like a lot of you know
especially when it comes like women in
games like i've never played a strong
woman woman character in a game like
laura craw cat
and felt you know what i i shouldn't
have played that like i've never i
usually don't care what that person is
like they could be i mean i've played
games that are animals like
i think it's it's just about you know
the more you see
good positive influence like uh i can't
remember one the one from for spoken
what's her name oh yeah yeah yeah
damn i know those guys are making it but
i know the character yes uh character
female but i do think
i do think because you know and
compulsions game addict or project i
believe project midnight is going to be
also midnight yeah yeah
well i do think that there needs to be a
company
that will
help other companies with different
hairstyles different you know tones
because i feel like
because let's be right here you know
there's a lot of companies that's not in
america there's a lot of companies that
you know especially a lot of eastern
they probably don't even see black
people there so like like i think there
needs to be like an outsourced studio
that someone could go to that does
nothing but customize
does like customization for
for everyone not just you know because
let me
like be real with you like i've never
cared about stuff like that
but it's never i've never felt like i
couldn't make a character that didn't
look like me you know what i'm saying
like you see attica always make him i
can't make me
no but it's a good discussion right
because like mama micah said you know
one of the frustrations you know
especially was always hair right it was
just like yeah the hair wasn't right i
go with the ball options yeah and then
like you know i don't want to call
certain games out but you know it's
certain games that let's be real you
know as a person of color you go to the
character creator and you're like
is
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
spend like like 45 minutes yes character
yeah i didn't know and i'm like
and he's like why did you get through
somebody's like i use a preset i don't
care like he's like and i was like i was
like cog you're literally under a mask
they can't see none of
it's so ridiculous because even people
give me credit for my mass effect
trilogy
representation like i spent so much time
in there because i was like okay they
got this option i can do this i can do
that they get the total right shape not
to mention if they start letting him
like adjust
like like the the how like fat and stuff
is oh yeah i gotta have a muscular shoe
well it's not even just that like you
can make customize the
you can customize the nose like your
cheekbones yeah you give all those
things the cog
he's probably just going to play that
that's as far as he's getting listen man
i love it man but yeah it's real i'm
glad we had discussion last thing i want
to give you credit for barbara biker was
um when we're talking about you know
protagonists of color
we you shared one that really hit home
was was lee from um the the walking dead
and i thought that was awesome you know
the way you described them and for the
people who haven't heard you talk to
colin about it like why does lee from
the walking dead the telltale series why
does he mean so much to you
yeah lee was just he was a father figure
to clementine and that is something that
we lack so much in media is strong black
father figures
and so i'm playing this game and you
have this adorable child that you're
trying to keep safe and you have you
step up and just seeing that the way
that he had dealt with like prejudice um
you know when people find out about his
past or essentially you know find out
the situation that he was involved in
prior to like the start of the game and
he's trying to deal with all of that
while being the the only person taking
care of this little girl in this crazy
situation
and he was just a fantastic character
he's calm he's level-headed he's he's
smart he wasn't at any point you know he
wasn't over the top he was just a real
person it felt like and it was part of
representation it's not just about skin
color it's also about you know who you
are
for me as a kid i grew up watching like
hey arnold and realizing all these kids
are poor and that's how i grew up and so
it's not just about how people look it's
also seeing your situation you know
seeing single parent households seeing
people that are low income
and that's what i hope we see even more
of in games is not just diversity of how
people look but you know characters that
maybe they're low income they have
single parent families things like that
to just so you can relate more to the
game when you relate to it that's when
you get so invested in characters that's
when you really feel like i'm having an
experience here and not just pressing
buttons for 40 hours absolutely and not
to mention that that would fix a lot of
things society-wise because it's like
you know you play this character and
it's like oh this is the truth so i was
like no i've literally had to do that in
my life like it will bring a lot of
spotlight to some of the dumb stuff
people have to do yeah no absolutely so
important and i'm so glad you touched on
that mama mike that that was awesome
that was awesome because we need more of
that it's it's bigger than that too like
because it's it's economic it's social
it's so much because when you see it
it resonates because you're like man
i've been through that i could relate i
am now even more invested in this game
you know kind of thing it's cool it's
cool so i want to move on because you
know time is limited but we got to ask
the question
in the realm that we always ask our
guests so i need
mama micah's top five video games or
franchises of all time
no pressure let's go
all right well number one is going to be
red dead redemption every time
number two it's going to be witcher 3.
you're a huge witcher fan i love the
books i love the games
gonna have you back every week
every week
i'd say number three is probably gonna
be gears three okay um that got me into
the series two is a really close
runner-up the horde and two was honestly
better but three has the multiplayer
five has the best multiplayer so far
though
so i put the s3 at number three uh spec
ops the line
let's go
i really love smack ops the line that's
a game that i haven't i haven't played
anything of that same caliber in a long
time it had the story had the phenomenal
weapons and mechanics there was nothing
like it at the time
and i i actually you know played it on
the hardest difficulty i never do that
in games but i just wanted to keep
playing it okay i couldn't put it down
all right one more say number five this
will be controversial but
it's gonna be seventh dragon three code
vfd from the nintendo 3ds the 3ds okay
okay this is that's that is a unique one
you surprised me because
i thought for sure
viva pinata would be on this list oh
well i almost said the order 1886 as
well i mean i could do a top 10
easy so
that's in the 10. that's it
oh yeah viva pinata is is an amazing
game that i genuinely adore i have the
prima guides still those are like my
prized possessions
i'm sure those are worth money oh yeah i
miss private guys oh those those are
like your bible like you if you got some
good ones with the games yeah yeah yeah
yeah that was i mean that was that came
that was like it came with tekken yeah
[Laughter]
1886 listen i'm with kane too i love the
damn order 1886. yep they like out of
the gameplay was derivative of gears and
it wasn't as good as gears but
everything around that world and those
characters beautiful i want to see again
but you won't see it again here shout
out to jim ryan that's not happening
anyway
the thing is those gears didn't get
where gears was without other
games you know
really putting it it's that's why like
when it comes to the days gone like i
agree with what they did but at the same
time i'm like
you know order 1886 like days gone like
those could have been your flagships if
you would have actually keep doing they
means to them exactly like the origins
of gears come from like went back
there's another game
yeah
no i'm just gonna say it's funny the
chat is hilarious right now they love
her pick somebody like big bobble biker
a permanent host she's a [ __ ]
we always ask is uh favorite console of
all time and why
oh okay it's probably gonna be xbox 360
because that's what got me into gaming
as an adult gaming was always something
i enjoyed as a kid but it wasn't really
accessible i didn't have many games i
didn't really have any of the big
consoles and as an adult when i finally
had my own money and i could you know
buy games that i wanted 60 was what got
me into it
that's what i'm talking about you heard
that when she got an as an adult and she
got her own money she went to the store
and chose green that's what i'm talking
about you ridiculous
[Music]
again tremendous video game history
amazing as a content creator love the
unboxings love everything you're doing
as far as you know just animate jrp it's
just tremendous and then obviously with
last day we are we are last stand family
you know i mean so it's awesome she's
the coordination makes things happen i
got a chance to meet me him so i got a
chance to be there um i was probably a
little stressed i didn't get a chance to
talk to you as much as i wanted to
because i was stressed for my first live
show so i'm like kind of getting in the
zone kind of thing but with the next one
we will definitely have more of these
discussions of course you're coming back
in the realm at some point when
schedules are loud but put your hands
together for the amazing mama mike the
last day of media in the building and uh
yes i know because right now we gotta
respect her targeting we gotta get her
out of here soon so um everyone who do
your uh outros to mama micah start with
addict first wouldn't say anything to
mama micah
i appreciate you coming on i don't
really know like a whole whole lot about
you um so i know that you're looking for
your research no no i'm just just being
honest i'm just being honest
i'm just being honest so you know um she
she likes anime so i think i like her
more than solve at this point
no no no
red dead in the witcher trump's anime
any day sorry
i'll be watching the
yeah so you know i definitely appreciate
you coming on like
we just want
when we made this like we we just want
to have a good time talking to you know
good people and it's nice because you
know
the way the industry works sometimes
that's not easy yeah and it's nice to
have someone on that you know just has
multiple passwords not just gaming yeah
like adam
uh and you know i don't really talk
about like my anime side because the
moment i talk about they're like addict
i don't want to hear this move on so you
know that's the comments
yeah well yeah i don't talk about anime
on the show right now
good to you but you know i definitely
appreciate you coming on it was it was
uh
your your background i was a little
disappointed you didn't play pokemon on
that uh that sp but you know we will
move past that so you can defend
yourself no she said
i'm not much of a pokemon person thank
you like i said the right side of
history right out of history
no no and lord soft glad he was able to
stay ready to make it for mama mike i'm
so happy yeah i know you listen
i could i couldn't miss this i could
have missed it mike is a pleasure to see
you again i only got to meet you briefly
at the last time media event but um i
have to say um we didn't touch on the
the mama moniker like where does that
come from because the thing is like you
you seem to have like a calming effect
so i think he seems to question that but
i might be wrong good question yeah uh
yeah no there's no children at all
i have always been the mom of my friend
group we'd go out to party and i'd be
the one with a water bottle and
ibuprofen and snacks in my purse i
always had like nature valley granola
bars and we'd be at this like rage party
and i'm prepared i'm so i was always the
mom of the group was the joke with my
friends you had the hangover
she was that friend when they talked
she's like no don't do that
designated drama driver yes
salute
yeah so
the thing is yeah you do it it feels
like you do have that calming effect
over like last stand like you know yeah
everybody knows collin's history or
whatnot is that any other but
you know for a long time now
specifically since you've kind of come
into the picture it's like it's just
this calming effect all of all over last
damn media that it's like ah you know
keep them knuckleheads alive you know
what i mean
i'm sure i'm sure she's kept calling out
of trouble in the past too we just don't
know but
it's so cool that that relationship i i
love it lord lord
king anything to say to a mama bite
going all the way out
well
i love a woman of color um in this
medium and uh
she's uh excelling in excellence right
but what i do love the most is your
collectibles yes and the fact that you
said with your first bucks that you went
to xbox so
with this being said
you could come here anytime you like
the door is open
and we are welcoming you back trust and
believe
i i just needed that today
oh god
now what you need to do just to really
test his his words go go make that i'm
i'm switching to playstation video
all that blue
no because she's just told you if she
has the top 10 the order this is the
first thing he's going to do he's going
to go on his phone and be like
unfollowed
don't listen to him amazing i told you
don't look at it
anyway amazing history again the
legendary lady baba biker enjoy your
sunday absolute pleasure and of course
you will be back in the realm
a pleasure absolute pleasure to have a
good one
thank you so much for having me have a
great day you too oh my god
especially the rest of the show you
definitely don't want to be part of it
about it it's about to get messy with
kids
but have a good one talk to you soon
bye-bye see you no no you want
so i'll get that popping for you um
last week's poll results are in and the
people have spoken with the recent
success of the meta quest 2 and the
anticipation of playstation vr ii how
how should xbox approach any potential
future involvement in the vr space the
winner at a very close four-way poll at
48 of the vote was partnered with an
established vr platform holder to
integrate xbox game pass platform group
coming in at second place at 24 percent
of the vote was don't enter the vr space
and focus strictly on console gaming
group in third place at 18 percent of
the vote develop your own vr headset in
the gaming space to compete and then
last place was the messi lords at eight
percent of the vote i don't care i'm
owning all your nfts in the metaverse
group
messi
um yeah man i'll jump in i'm actually
surprised by this you know i'm actually
lord oculus i guess now so i'm actually
surprised people want xbox to part i
thought the the uh
the prevailing thought would be for them
to focus strictly on gaming so that was
interesting
want them to fail you know funny that
was the prevailing thought before this
sort of you know kind of resurgence in
the over the past couple of months
because before that we were like yo you
know we don't know if xbox they still
have i've been proven that they get you
know they
the games and they're coming out they're
going to be good and then we have you
know 2021 yeah and banging after banger
so everybody's kind of confident now
like hey why not why not dip your toe
into this this is about integration i
mean
leave him alone
we're going to do a vr and you know what
we don't care everybody going white
unless we going tezzi
move it over
pay since let me roll back a little bit
um
we have eliad salomo [ __ ] with the 15
15 shekels those are israeli shekels ah
absolutely salutations to the realm
salutations to the realm regards and may
all have a great day and evening can't
wait for the great content and also the
messiness
always messy
and we have don otaku five dollar super
chat after that last trailer horizon god
of war and star filled in the bushes
kirby in the forgotten land is the game
of the year they did
they gave my mans a gun yeah they did
like they gave him a blunderbuss
then we have sith lord two dollars super
chat gears is my favorite co-op game
with my best friend yes gives an
excellent co-op game
we have senua's dad two dollar super
chat
vegeta is the greatest
[Laughter]
he can't be there would be no goku
you're making no sense she loves him
that's not
then we have auburn king two pounds
super chat one piece is great too has
real depth to it yes
yeah so long that it would take me a
whole year to win so good
no yeah they did the statistic you'd
have to like quit your job and for six
months do nothing but watch one piece
and watch it yeah to finish everything
yeah crazy wow that's good oh is that
that's not how many over a thousand
episodes yes that's ridiculous that's
crazy
taco ten dollars in a chat shout out to
xbox for having all the black queen
protagonists jen ronnie from the gunk
legola from red fall and the lady in the
trailer from state of decay three we
don't know this video shout out to lady
the trailer
and the protagonist of project midnight
i hope that's the protagonist they they
kind of showed it they didn't really say
that was the protagonist but i i hope so
um then we have lucius augustus five
dollar super chat facts addict i'm sick
of my ashy black characters with tones
get them jurgens aveena something
some palmer some farmers uh what's up
with these darker tones yes
they tend not to have those tones you
know
what's up with the seizures man
everybody inside the ball you guys are
you guys remember um
it was what what was that call it was
one of the south parks i think it was
the second one where the difficulty was
your skin color yeah
made a video about this real issue is is
gaming is too insular games are made in
the west and japan not enough rest of
the world has stories to tell we only
see things through the eyes of outsiders
when they make content about us
that is true and it always has a
different tilt to it like you know
you look at gta gta is a parody of
americana through the eyes of british
people yeah
then we have
mandingo
[Laughter]
there we go here we go five dollar super
chat i'm very offended by the lack of
options and character creation i can
never augment below the man cut hence my
name
pause excellence
he needs he needs a girth meter
here please share this out hit that like
hit that like button like button with
the algorithm
how do we get that helps with the
algorithm
that nice redirect king i appreciate
that here we got pragmatic eagle five
thousand
another very interesting guest great
story diverseation games
gotta love it salute to the iop no doubt
to mama micah yeah then we have mr
irishman five pound super chat
too much gears multiplayer slander takes
place in the in this room great to see a
guest with actual good days multiplayer
games hashtag stop the gears slander we
love games i'm just not the multiplayer
gears game but yeah you you stop drop
and roll go ahead and go back and stop
you
there we go uh we got reggie mobile yeah
10 months
great show as always lords mama micah
was a cool guest thank you awesome
salute to you sir
then we have jake fonzarelli gave me
five dollars is mama micah single oh
wait i'm not yeah
neither is
she
both of you are not
seriously great guests and loving the
show as usual brothers p.s to my wife i
was kidding
absolutely
salute
there we have that we have flame five
dollars from chap i'm not saying i don't
like the fatherly thing and god of war i
just wish it was realistic i get that
uh where's the electronic section to
drop off the kick wow
you know what anything mad at trey is
this i don't want any parts of atreus in
that game not not about atreya's oh then
we got mandango mcstickens
[Laughter]
[Music]
he said girth meter i'm dead
yo there is actually a game that has
that i can't really call it right isn't
that cyberpunk no the cyberpunk
cyberplug that's what it is
the game that hasn't come out yet just
saying loving the content happy new year
to you as well you already know let's
get into it i want to get solved at
least one topic because i know he's got
a role all right so look let's get into
it this is king's topic but i guess i
will set it up for you king if you don't
mind
um yeah xbox sales success um estimates
indicate xbox series x and s may be
selling nearly as well as the
playstation 5. phil dominus maximus
cerrelia spencer in a recent
looking king ty's article while he
didn't give any specific numbers he made
it clear this is a record for xbox he
says supply is actually as big as it's
ever been it's that demand that is
exceeding supply for all of us at this
point we've sold more of this generation
of xboxes which is xbox series x and s
than we had any previous generation of
xbox wise king swinging chains um shout
out to game industry gameindustry.biz
xbox series snx hits 1 million uk sales
in a strong december for the uk monthly
charts they said 560 000 game consoles
were sold in december in the uk and as
far as xbox and they said um now the
switch was number one in december but
just behind nintendo was the series x
and s which enjoyed a bumper 108 percent
increase in sales month on monday
it is the previous month year it is the
biggest month yet for xbox series x and
s even beating its launch month in
november 2020 the increase was driven by
a significant increase in stock of xbox
console and then they said um it means
playstation 5 slips to third place
position this month but it was still
successful
but it was still a successful sales
period for sodium platform which enjoyed
a 28 increase in sales compared with
november and the second biggest month to
pay playstation 5 outside of it's launch
book so yeah big news going on king
definitely had a lot to say actually um
now you don't ever stop with that shane
no i'm not
won't stop that's clarifying just
firefighting so look so pretty much i
want to add one other thing before i
give king the floor um shout out to paul
tassie because he said um after phil
spencer's comments he said this is
significant because um basically the
double sku approach and he said we
talked about nico partner analyst daniel
ahmad says that based on the past xbox
one and xbox 360 year one numbers 12
million and 10 10.4 million respectively
that means phil spencer is saying that
xbox series x and s have shipped at
least 12 12-minute 12-minute units which
makes it seem that the the gap between
both consoles may be closer than
anticipated once thought you know for
this generator so king
the floor is yours uh would you you seem
very elated about this news let's talk
about it it's just like
you know when you kept talking it was
just like an uppercut and it was like a
left hook and it was like an uppercut
then it was like are you saying you're
getting uppercut and
all i heard was
guys in the corners that like to count
numbers
these dudes that be on my timeline they
be like your king man is selling two to
one
yo no you did say that that series s was
gonna outsell a playstation it did
it has
and it will continue to do so
ridiculous we are at a point people
right now with
disbelief is happening people are
running through the streets they're
screaming they're yelling they're
panicking
no this this is not really what happened
to because basically what's going on if
you see the numbers now they're talking
about numbers
okay so okay let's let's let's keep this
energy right uh-huh let me hear okay
let's say it's shipped right
go to the store and go get one exactly
exactly
this is the first time that
shipped is
whatever the number shift is is damn
near close to what's sold through it's
gone okay so so now that this energy is
happening right now you don't like this
energy i'm about to give you this energy
is right here is about to blow your mind
25 of those playstations have not been
turned on so they're sitting in
somebody's warehouse someplace
so
all right so now
the scalpers have all the places
this is when you're a hot commodity
you're hot right you're burning you're
on fire nobody won an xbox right
but they sold
enough
enough for you to turn over and they'd
be like oh my god he's
images in the mirror is closer than they
appear
yo you hit
and at this point right now
there's more little serious esses out
there more little little mans out there
all nerdy on you disgustingly like this
and they're doing it off the vert
because you said that we don't got no
games but apparently this is what's
happening right now see this is what
happens when you have a dry season
dry season oh god okay so we gotta keep
going in september
nothing was there
there's nothing for nobody to purchase
that is true so nobody needs to go out
and buy your whole your wares but you're
gonna say king you can't find a
playstation in the store and this is
true
so we're gonna keep with your 15 million
right
so
statistical says that they sold in this
period of time 12 to 15 million so did
xbox and we're on your bumper and i'm
saying we we're not an xbox podcast i'm
an xbox dude and right now
all you do is that like to count numbers
and look at people's pockets because i
got mine
do you have yours
you [ __ ] uh you can't call out the
pocket watchers kick that's what we do
now they're gonna move the goal post you
know every time they're gonna be like oh
but what's the tax rate
[Laughter]
xbox don't give numbers i don't believe
until xbox getting numbers by e
i just want to know how do you guys feel
that your twitter line is easy now
because i know a lot of people are quiet
now
let's get started first cause i know
it's time it's limited i don't want to
get so
sorry man what what we thinking you know
with these numbers phil comes out which
is kind of a characteristic in the sense
that he didn't say the numbers direct
but he definitely left it for
interpretation when you make a statement
about you know
they broke records pretty much yeah i
think it was funny is like you know
obviously in the xbox one generation
they were like we don't talk about
engagement now we're not talking about
all this stuff right and now when the
numbers are coming
let these numbers leak out a little bit
let's talk about these numbers this is
the greatest
episode
so it's just funny that that that that
conversation is even out there right yes
but
like we said a couple of shows back then
um that little man's doing what it's
supposed to do
and the thing about the little man is
but the genius of it right that we
didn't know until it got announced and
we knew what it was
is the fact that apart from resolution
there isn't that much of a discernible
downgrade in power right
so when you get that message out then
people understand that it's still a
next-gen console that you're still going
to get the vast majority of that
experience apart from resolution
that's continuing to move the needle
what's great about it is is the fact
that
you could they can manufacture that one
at a at a larger scale simply because
it's a smaller machine and probably has
two you make two for every one well
every one series x right yeah
that's huge in this environment that is
huge and in an environment when i
i remember one day the two skews for the
playstation got announced i was like you
know what that's smart okay that come
that combats the series s in that even
though it's still a hundred dollars more
expensive right the digital one yeah
even though it's better than 200 right
yeah it's a 100 difference and my
thinking was like you know what it's
still the p the specs of the ps5 are
still the same across the right that was
the talk
if you could see the comparison in the
store you still might go for the the
extra hundred dollars on the playstation
right right
i mean that argument's kind of out the
window because there aren't any right so
forget about that but at the same time i
think it's it's it's it's imperative and
they did they've done a good job i
didn't feel they were doing this in the
beginning is that you
the power of the s has to be spoken
about a lot of people look at the s yeah
and and just because of how it looks
comparable to a 1s yeah it could be it
can be confusing to the you know the
general consumer whatever yeah oh but
they took those off the shelves oh yeah
they're gone they're good they're gone
they're going but if you have a series
of houses
though oh yeah let's get into that
conversation
yeah yeah listen
i don't know got a playstation for you
yo i'm gonna be i'm gonna be real with
y'all uh-oh i don't know i don't know
that that does anything like because
they've already they've all i mean they
were going to sell playstation 4
throughout through the end of this year
anyway right
but now they have to market it because
they want you to buy them so they they
can get them sales numbers up for gt7
right for god of war and for horizon but
here's the thing so i've like you know
the talk let's let's just get to it
right which is right generations talk
right they were saying that why would
you buy a system and you need a new one
now we see the stock stuff now they seem
to be they did the reverse pivot they
got lashed at rightfully sold right but
now as a result because of the whether
it be the supply issues the chip issues
whatever then they're going to make it
more ps4s do you think
now this forces them to stay
more cross-generational titles as
opposed to xbox which seems to be
pushing in direction of
next-gen only which is serious
we don't know any of their party stuff
beyond god of war right specifically
right do we know anything else their
first party stuff we don't know what my
impression would be that naughty dog's
next game next game apart from factions
i think francis would be cross-gen right
but apart whatever their next thing is
oh let's talk about this
do we think the last of us remake is
cross gen
i mean at this point i'm going to have
to say yes like yes because yeah if they
okay
i'll cut you off there
has they officially said spider-man is
the next gen only experience
not officially
not really i saw people saying they did
but i tried to fight it and i couldn't
find any articles
because if you think about it if you
think about it
spider-man's next year
yeah so it's just like
maybe that maybe next year's when they
start breaking off but like
but people have speculated that that's
that's an extra exclusive game and i
feel like because they were getting
dragged through the street so bad over
the crosston statement
how hard is it to make a a tweet that
says yes this is the next gen experience
it's like
like but they they don't they kind of
like
let's
it's like a rock before we have to
officially say no this is a cross gin
game do you think as a result of maybe
them seeing internally yo we can't get
these ps5s out there no these dudes are
on a bumper
yeah i mean so people
hold up people in the chat are saying
they did someone sent me a link because
i tried to find it i could not find a
big guy and i don't i don't remember any
point of them saying that it's the next
general game i don't remember we would
have had that discussion if they had
said yes next gen only game if you only
have a playstation 5. if you have a
playstation 4
i'm going to be playing right next to
you christopher hart
no no attic you're gonna take it out
when it comes out show me that link now
don't wait till it comes out yeah i
don't know what he's saying i don't know
what he's challenging we're just asking
but i'm gonna tell you this i just don't
know that that you know you having to
put marketing out for more playstation
4s yeah it's just it doesn't feel like
that like when when the thing is that
microsoft is get is selling you right
it's selling you a next-gen console that
you can actually find
that that's uh
now the thing is obviously
obviously the exclusives right yeah of
course of course
people in the chat are saying wolverine
i do believe that that is the next gen
only game that's gonna make 2026. yeah
exactly that makes sense
i have a question yes
since the playstation 4 is being
manufactured again
um
and you can get a brand new playstation
4 this year
is the playstation 4 holding back the
next game
oh my god all right this one i got to
let him rock i got it no no no you make
sense yeah i gotta let keg rock because
let's be real the the design lords we
heard it all like yo
miles around this is a next-gen
experience this this is why you buy a
console i seen articles they were like
xbox is is holding back the fun
of the new generation we are not able to
tap in to them
it's like it's like i've said before
like i am still on that stance that
right you know if a game isn't designed
exclusively for a next-gen console they
are a lot of you know engineering things
that you can't do but if you look at it
from a standpoint rise center roam was
on the connect yeah so
like obviously that version that we got
that version probably wouldn't have been
able to run on the kinect but the
majority of these first-gen games yeah
they can run on previous gen consoles
they they just they make that cut to
give value to that player of course it's
not necessarily yeah you know return
can't be ran on the ps4 sony decided for
not to be honest absolutely the only
thing we got it we got to give kingness
and this was the tour oh no i'm not
fighting this yeah
because the talk was remember xbox was
very transparent with stuff like halo
infinite and stuff like that they're
going to be cross-generational for about
a year before they switch over they got
dragged for being transparent whereas
opposite sony did say hey we believe in
generations if you spend this they gotta
drive for a good couple right then you
see the pivot now right stock or what
have you now it's the pivot now it's
kind of ironic because the system you
know we don't believe in all this stuff
but the system that's going to be
holding back
is the other system though
i believe in all the stuff that i'm
saying i mean at the end of the day
if it's
i don't think it's holding xbox back
because the only games that are holding
we next gen that are holding playstation
games back is their own games right like
horizon not being a next-gen exclusive
that's not holding xbox back that's
holding playstation back oh yeah
yeah yeah no absolutely absolutely
because you know what and and i'm gonna
keep it a hundred mm-hmm because a lot
of dudes oh you're gonna keep it 100 you
got 200 now yeah you don't know so i'm
gonna keep it 100 because a lot of dudes
be keeping the 50 cent um
and a lot of you dudes be capping
right so now and i and i really want a
real honest answer for all the people
that's in the chat right
do you think playstation is holding back
this next gen
put a one in the check if yes put it two
i honestly feel like you know i was
upset
when they said they ramping them up
they're pulling them back they said yo
barney
what we're back in business baby turn up
that playstations which ones
i'll jump right in okay cool i put a
nice three yeah did you get your ball
did you get your bars off yeah
did you get your balls off on this
object because i wanted to go right
after yeah i mean when it comes down to
it like i don't necessarily think like
it is the numbers people sitting the
same ship to all
they're sold let's be real here like
sure there might be some xbox series at
s's like
on the shelves
in certain parts of the world
but people sitting there though
what's funny is they'll show a picture
on twitter
it like uh like after before you buy it
no no no
picture of his local target
it's like they they pop in there and
they're like yo when you restock it and
they just go there to take a picture the
moment they're restocked
it's just like look like i get it
uh why am i going to believe some random
twitter
over over people like gaming forte that
works in retail that tells me they fly
off the shelves in a couple days like
it's just like look like i don't think i
think they're probably about three to
four million difference uh because
people are sitting there oh you know uh
they're they're a million no they're not
because sony
announced
numbers in like october or something and
they were at like 13 million or 14. so
unless you guys want me to believe that
sony didn't sell one ps5 in the holiday
of course
of course there's clearly yeah there's
clearly maybe four to five million
difference but all i want to ask the
chat
is a company that was dragged through
the mud for eight years
why is there a four to five million
difference
yeah i mean let me jump in it it should
be way more on one side but it's not
well basically what it shows is one
twitter is an echo chamber that is that
reflective of the entire real world of
what's going on in the industry that's
just one pocket right um you know i told
people from the beginning you know attic
king i told people i said look
regardless of how people feel even at
the start of generations i said this is
going to be a competitive generation i
told people that right and what happens
is it's like solve it's like every year
it's a new season it's a new slate and
people have to recognize us we've been
around the game long time we understand
you know we've seen the most dominant
things and all of a sudden you'll come
back down to earth and then it's
competitive and then maybe the next you
know the other one take off people just
die there's no guarantee because you won
the chip last generation it is a
foregone conclusion you win the
championship and i'm not saying that
xbox is definitely one of the chip i
just said
they are going i know king said yeah
king put his chest i salute the kick he
always put his chest i told you all this
is a straight dub coming to you
uh youtube youtube in the bushes for me
you guys are good yeah oh no we're good
oh wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait it's it's live on-board
yeah
is they found out it's like we give you
two hours and you out that's it so yeah
that's so crazy how metered it feels
like
they knew you you they knew you missed
behavior
before you you take off uh saul because
i know my mom's about to leave
why not but he's literally about i don't
know
i just wanna like hear his opinion on
like uh stalker and then get delayed
real quick yeah real quick
i mean stalker i think i think the
general consensus was that stalker
despite being in development for keep in
mind red fall looks like it might get
delayed too yeah i mean king was talking
about this and it makes sense i i don't
think unreal 5 is quite ready yet i
think there's still some kinks there um
and this you know you add that on top of
just cover just pushing everything back
at least six months right um i think i
don't even know that we see stalker this
year i think the i think the december
date is wishful thinking okay um but
take your time with that game i for me
i don't want stalker coming out half big
because thought this is a chance for
stalker to appeal to the masses in a way
that stalker never did before so i i
want you to be the very best the best it
could be so take your time um but it
could be to me some unreal engine five
growing pace i i agree with king on that
um because it just seems like everything
that's that's trying to be like first in
line to use that yeah is is is kind of
running into some bumps in the road so
quick i've heard i'm sorry i'm sorry
continue you heard
yeah so i get cuz i heard some things
about just being able to like maximize
frame rate and stuff like that it's just
not quite there yeah we'll get it yeah
and then oh two quick hits for you
because because i want your opinion
before you leave um xbox 2022 lineup are
you concerned and second hitman three
game pass stuff how do you feel about
that
okay so first am i concerned about no
game pass again i i there's so much
stuff
they're bangers from last year that i
haven't gotten a chance to play so for
me personally it it take delays whatever
man i i'm never really gonna be able to
hit all that stuff when it comes out
anyway for somebody who's ready for that
next big
next big game when it comes out yeah i
can see you be you know if you're not
into the smaller stuff that comes to
game pass then maybe okay but again we
haven't heard everything that's coming
out true um you know we haven't heard
where forza is and stuff like that so
yeah
for forget all these other games being
delayed how about some of those february
developers delay them games
we need one or two of those delayed a
month february is looking bonkers yeah
nuts so um and then hit man y'all know
how i feel about it
murder is the american murder one of the
most amazing sort of uh stealth
comedy sandboxes to ever you know they
they took that oh i used to love old
hitman
and i i understood why other people
didn't love it as much i understood
there was quirkiness there and then with
the reboot they they really they created
a game that appealed to the masses and
they also polished what it was to be a
hitman game and they got it um
it kind of had a little bit of a
downturn when they decided to re release
hitman 2 episodically which i thought
worked for me
um i'm sorry was it hitman one that they
did episode
it worked for me because those are the
type of levels that you really want to
replay multiple times to see the
different ways to get through them
that's part of the joy but i understand
people wanting to have the whole game at
once right absolutely so um to have the
entire trilogy in game pass
play hit man hit man when it came to
last year hit me with all the dlc right
that's everything that's everything the
whole whole thing
and i think a lot of them you increase
and is it with is it with the the next
gen upgrades they have been talking
about did they say that yeah yeah so i
think ray tracing with that i think it's
like i think it's like ray tracing 60fps
like it's my game is gorgeous as it is
fellas
so i mean i mean let's let's be real
here man if you ain't played hitman yet
any of them no a lot of the best place
to play hitman right now is on the xbox
platform on the 20 years he's on that
game pass you hear that fellas
the next gen experience
ain't nothing holding us back
all right what's up okay you got to go i
am yeah yeah let me you want me to show
you guys it actually it came back for me
quickly so
it gave me a little bit of extra time
yes please let me read these super tests
um
thank you
we got j fonz the homie the brother
fonzarelli gave me two dollars for chat
why y'all got dudes with the weirdest
names
we attract weirdos in the chat that's
fine that's right they are weirdos they
are weirdos we love them
there we go
remember for three months uh tell them
king i whatever smoke king was talking
about in that book
tell em king whatever random
then we got jd i think it's jd gamer i
might have cut it off daddy gamer uh
remember for 22 months lord bronze thank
you my brother wow absolutely hello king
night
i was waiting for that
he's just waiting for that light their
butts up for all the disrespect pause
all the disrespect and disbelief ah
their minds are crumbling the walls are
falling in on them
[Laughter]
[Music]
and now you got him out of pocket
i told you my boy was going to show up
to you
there we go lucious augustus five
dollars but yeah daniel lahmad is
estimating that the ps5 and xbox series
are only a few million units apart 12 to
13 million for xbox series and maybe 14
15 for playstation that is correct hey
adam numbers are close
and we got scrub nurse ten dollars if we
chat the best and the best ability is
say it with me availability congrats to
all the parents gamers and microsoft for
seeing the power of little man price is
king shout out to the panel and chat on
a new year no doubt yeah they it was a
genius move it really was
then we got lord of roughness out five
pound super chat series s owner right
here and since day one in november 2020
i have a great time
on my xbox every day still not looking
at ps5 with any envy okay i told you it
was a piano
yeah we got jd gamer 20 of a chat
everybody doubted little man the media
the sony defense force armchair devs
fake business gurus where are they now i
see you little sony dudes hiding in the
bushes get out here and take this
whooping like you deserve jesus why is
this like a payback podcast
[Laughter]
[Music]
shout out to messi lords in 2021 or 2022
i guess he means no ps4 will not hold
back ps5 pc will wow since all those
games will come to pc tv
[Laughter]
then we got bay area five dollars
what's up lords show is fire as always
game passes killing it um hey cognito
we're only an hour and a half away from
the showdown in big d pause go nine
minutes
i respect it crazy it's gonna be crazy
there we go lord of roughness once again
five pounds super chat once the smoke is
cleared i bet the leak will come out the
horizon forbidden west is dlc just like
mama ronaldo ended up beat hashtag just
say wow
wow wow wow what i didn't tell very
messy then we got
auburn king five times super chat i
couldn't find one ps5 heading to
christmas just pre-ordered for end of
january xbox series x was available in
the uk are sony holding stock for
horizon
that doesn't make sense
horizon is weeks away like one kid
smooth told me i don't know um
i didn't check it which gets me usually
pretty knowledgeable and stuff but
apparently like didn't i if i remember
correctly i do remember this i just i
didn't look it up but didn't sony a
couple months ago saying that
they lowered their the amount of ps5
that they can realistically make up
until march of 2022. yeah i don't know
that's all we got with any time
okay uh
let me see we got money
good morning lords welcome back looking
forward to a big 2022 let the smoke run
as we do yes yes
then we have one more also i must have
skipped one yeah i did see another one
we got jd gamer once again five dollar
super chat people forget that he said at
least 12 million shipped who's to say
that it's not 13 14 or even 15 million
so they yeah they give those rand you
know those rounded numbers so
approximate all right last one for me
five dollar super chat these zealots
wanted some of that crystal d until this
spider-man came out limp wow
now they don't want the crystal decents
they working on joanna dark wow
anyway
yeah you got to bounce but before you
about to say i didn't get my finish my
balls were just like look it's going to
be a competitive gin you know every a
lot of people mocked as king called it
the doubles two-prong approach the
bayonet you know what i'm saying little
man is an impressive piece of tech it
shows that people want it you know and
it's to me it's very impressive
considering let's be honest you know the
2020 launch lineup was barron
and they they improved over time in 2021
they had a phenomenal strong year but
it's very impressive they did so much
well out the gate with the software now
being there initially and yeah future's
right this is going to be a competitive
gen the ps4 thing they're going to have
to adapt you know because obviously the
stock situation and we're going to see
about the cross generational thing but
look it's going to be a fun gen y'all
but solve get your balls off brother
appreciate you matt
uh love y'all i appreciate it i'm sorry
i cannot stand about that i gotta
there's two more there's two last ones
i'll just read them quick rating blade
five pounds super chat hello all king is
right remember sony reduced productivity
of one million ps5 and waited two months
to reveal ps4 one million in production
whether it's ps that's another thing are
they base ps4s or ps4 pros
based ps4 is running any of these games
this is probably a problem
um
then we have a yeah so that's that's a
question to be asked and we have
splendiferous two dollars super chat is
lord addict a crossing guard a lot of
orange jesus
get him get him out of here talking
crazy
finally the last one necromancer sale
five dollar super chat don't forget
about microsoft all access getting xbox
consoles out to people too that is true
as well though
i love y'all i will see you next week
chat i apologize in advance for any the
butchering over the butchering
[Laughter]
[Music]
two delay i'll get raiden blade five
pounds super chat so ps4 is not holding
back this gen and ps4 pro is the better
consoles never ts little man again never
doubt little man again okay whatever
this i ain't solved i'm sorry um look so
let's talk about it man um i'm gonna set
it up one part of it for you addict is
your topic stalker two delay i know you
wanted to talk about it on the official
uh twitter account stalkers we made a
decision to postpone the release of
stalker two heart of chernobyl to
december 8 2022 these additional seven
months of development are needed to
fulfill our vision and achieve the
desired state of the game so yeah it
looks like it's getting pushed back and
i know you also want to talk about
something else in relating to this as
far as the lineup for xbox so attic the
floor is yours let's talk about it
um okay
so just give me a second now you're good
you're having a hard time breathing not
brother oh man if you're not feeling
well i know you're going through yeah
yeah you don't have to do that i got you
bro i got you so look let's talk about
it um
you know we we hear about the stalker
delay shout out for shout out gotta
support the whole team lords of
gaming.net my man nicholas down he had
the article above but beyond before a
lot of the masses talking about the
rumor that stalker 2 would be delayed
and obviously this was a big title that
was expected at the first half of the
year for microsoft but i think what alec
wanted to go at was kind of like
the first half
of 2022 maybe the first six to eight
months for the xbox console and the
lineup and the concerns there so um
attic if you're up to it you go if not
i'll just give it right in the king and
um
let's just talk about it man like what
are we feeling
the at the effects of this delay
anybody could i feel like
it's pretty
it's pretty self-explanatory like i do
think that
microsoft's probably going to have a
in terms of like their stuff
it's not a lot coming on and i don't
even really consider like like
uh stalker
three or four or seven i don't know
i don't really consider that part of it
i mean look like at the end of the day
their exclusives aren't gonna hit a
whole lot at the beginning of the year
it's gonna seem a little bit more like
this year but the thing is is like they
already got rainbow six extractions yes
um
it's possible they might snatch
something like dying like two i don't
know
but i think
i think we're gonna see a lot more of
game pass now the thing is is like look
does that excuse the fact that they
don't have that no but it's hard to
complain that you don't have exclusives
to play when they're giving you a steady
amount of games every month on game pass
to play
so
and that's something that you just don't
see on playstation when they're dry
they're they're dry dry like they're
they're dying of thirst like but
i mean it's it's it's it's just honest
like when xbox is dry they try to
accommodate with game pass third party
or
popular indies you know we had hades
last year we had the show we had
outriders like they tried to do
something around there it's like look
our first party game right right it is
what it is right but we got this stuff
over here massive
absolutely yeah yeah
absolutely in a game anomaly shot as he
said guys aren't you forgetting nobody
saves the world coming out the 18th yes
we will talk about it but okay let's get
to it man because uh you've had some i'm
gonna read the super chat from um oh yes
please raiden blade okay real quick
um
okay so
uh let's call a spade a spade because
when they have the dry season they had
their dry season uh from uh september
once they uh released that game
um
what was that that little cartoon game
that's multi-plat
[Music]
okay yeah and once uh kenneth came out
that was it and uh they had kenna until
until february
and they don't have a game pass
situation where they can go and snatch a
a third-party title real quick and just
throw it into their service uh they have
playstation now but again if playstation
now throws something in there it doesn't
resonate as well they could have
comparable stuff inside their platform
but
the reason why playstation now doesn't
hit the same way as game pass is because
day and date
means a whole lot more first party
titles dropping into your service means
a whole lot more and it seems like right
now microsoft can leverage the dry
season right quote unquote uh with this
ability to do what they're doing they
already have the eyeballs looking at
game pass for uh
you know quote unquote the first party
titles the triple a titles but then they
seeing all the benefits of getting games
that i waited for right i literally do
not run out to go purchase something
because of fear of purchasing and having
buyers regret
i is remorse
i do not excuse me do not want to spend
60 70 bucks on something and then find
out two weeks later it's inside game
pass i'm mad as hell i can use that
money to buy skins or i can actually buy
nintendo games that won't ever go to no
type of service for them so
that's where i'm at with it but
there's something more concerning with
these delays okay
all right i think epic live
and um
allegedly okay um
and i think it really has something to
do with uh kovit right
in the sense that their engine is not up
to snuff
because every game that has something to
do with unreal engine 5
has been delayed in some form of fashion
has been pushed back
at least excuse me yeah um
four to six months right
and um a lot of stuff that i'm hearing
like you know soft touched on it um
frame rate issues now if you go and you
put on the the matrix demo
that games it looks great but it looks
phenomenal in still shots
in execution in some places
some framing at some points okay
all right um you see certain things you
can point out certain stuff so is it as
completely rock solid as unreal engine 4
i don't think so
so i think some of the kinks aren't
being worked out yet i don't think they
have the certain workarounds and i think
when people try to implement certain
things that they're used to with unreal
engine 4 and they say in an unreal
engine 5 is just like attack on to
unreal engine 4 and it extends and and
bolsters the profile of unreal engine 4.
i think they're having an issue with
this and i think the language with the
developer and i'm not a developer no
okay but what i'm saying is every game
that seems to be utilizing this engine
seems to be the one coming up getting
the delay
no doubt i want to respect you you got
to head soon because i know you got
stuff going on or you okay
i'm good i'm just yeah i i'm letting you
guys
know no no i mean if king's finished
then i'll go but if king got more bars
no no no it's just um that i noticed
this and and i said it is concerning it
is concerning for the year of uh 2022
and i'm not going to sit here and papua
and say oh i wasn't looking forward to
it because i was yeah all right so um
stalker 2 got delayed and i had told
somebody that hitting me in the dm um i
think was big fat eli meanwhile was you
know
chatting back and forth and he was like
yo what do you think about the um
stalker two delay and i said nah i think
they're gonna hit they mark right and
then
it pops up a day later
boom and i'm like wow i was wrong yeah
you know um
now that that that's when my eyebrow
went up and i was like man maybe the
stuff that they are saying is true
you know and then that makes me start to
look at all the games right that's down
there and then microsoft's own internal
teams are utilizing this engine right to
the to the fullest so
really microsoft is going to be most
affected by this because the majority of
the teams are using unreal engine five
right
so what do you think are you comfortable
with them staying packed as it is you're
going like y'all gonna like the poll
question or do you think they need to be
aggressive with game pass moves for like
the first half that you know they lost
this major title at the top of the year
the good thing about the game pass thing
is we've seen without riders
that could be done at the last minute
yes like that's not something that could
that's not something that has to be on
six seven months they probably get a
better deal for six seven
if they go to some of these studios they
might show like a sign of weakness but
at the same time it's like look some of
our heavy hitters which you know uh
heavy hitters
care about them but some of them might
get pushed back to 2023 or the very end
of 2022 so it's like you know you might
have to go out here and you know spend
that money push a bag or two and we know
we know that there is money that they're
sitting on that they technically still
haven't used because apparently the
rumor shout out to jeff grubb we had one
to find and do it the rumor is you know
they have money that's allocated for
game pads just sitting there that you
know that could be you so i want to get
into it because um i hear what king is
saying you know i don't know i didn't
hear anything specifically in reference
to that but i'm a yeah
i'm just saying i'ma look up the uh what
we know is coming out yeah so give me a
couple minutes i got that too yeah i got
y'all got it we could we can break it
down yeah we can break it down
right so here's the thing you know
we can't i have to admit though you know
with any new engine like king is saying
on some level this is going to be a
learning curve right so i don't know i'm
not saying confirming that unreligion
file there's a problem i'm just saying
that that could be an issue we don't
know but at the end of the day here's
the thing like to me xbox their second
halves historically for the year are
always lit and this year to me is no
exception you still got you know most
likely death loops one year um
exclusivity should end that hopefully
may come hopefully you know september
october you know we're talking about
potentially a next gen four's a game
using only four but we have to see if
that hits that's there and of course my
favorite shot to god howard starfield
which is i am super pumped super excited
for you know if they put that release
date out so we know those are there yeah
like but there's this track record it
shows me that they'll be fine but here's
the thing you know
them first seven months yo now breaking
it down yeah it's rough now i'm gonna
break it down especially if they don't
do what they did last year right
this is what's really popping out addict
to me
january lit
rainbow six siege extraction
mass effect trilogy
hitman trilogy
that's lit for game pass like those are
mega joints
let me ask you a question because
february is a very stacked one let's
talk about so because i feel like we got
to be realistic to a point like
okay now i don't think they're going to
get the witch queen because they would
have announced that by now right um i
think that's good
you think it's a goal or nick no yeah
you said no you you felt that the
destiny thing is over yeah so i think
that you know the mate they might hit up
uh dinosaur warriors nine
that could be something they look out
dying like two
um they might hit up eldon ring at the
end
now i'm looking at march like march
isn't really
so here here's the three it's the reason
i'm saying much okay uh because there's
not a lot going on in march like in
terms of games
butts
so tunic is already on game pass right
no i'm talking about the general format
yeah i'm making a game
so to me
if i were microsoft and i it was like
look you know they gave me the option i
feel like
pick up
dying like two yeah ring yes because
elden ring is so far down you can count
that [ __ ] in march
it's the 25th so you know it's just like
look i think at the end of the day it's
probably going to be something like you
know it like in terms of like triple a
stuff like from middle to top like so
maybe i would put my money on something
like
dynasty warriors or dying like two
because i don't think they're going to
go for elderly i think they need that i
think dying light too makes the most
sense because it fits like king over
february 2nd right it fits the format
it's it's baltig i got you
no no no i i wasn't waiting till after
you finished it no that's cool yeah it
it fits the template you know the
cooperative game you know three four
players you know engagement i definitely
feels that like what i want to say is
this so look you got january you got
february you got crossfire x xbox
exclusive but not in game pass it's
exclusive the free to play that
multiplayer is free to play you know
what i'm saying so to me february story
you got to buy yes february still you
know people going they gotta assume
people go like that game gotta rape wow
for people to run out and say and go get
not to mention yeah
not to mention they could always
announce a game coming in from the from
the start right
they do stuff like octopi traveler
coming day and date on the platform the
same day it's announced so absolutely
there's always stuff like that that can
happen oh we got a ninja we got a
shinobi yeah yo it's hilarious
here
we go
we got dmv shinobi that's my man it's
hustling motivate salute but oh why are
you fixing that j we get them right um
yeah like i wish on that i just here's
the thing like no disrespecting to it
but like
that's not gonna be enough just yeah
that's why i say
if there's a round
no
you know they could just get out and
ring and leave dying like alone okay and
i feel like that would be strong enough
to to do more okay
all right
stop y'all what i'm going to do hold up
one more thing real quick king one more
thing real quick there is in march that
strangers would paradise final fantasy
origins they might want to try to pick
that up because it would show like oh
see we're getting some final fantasies
on the platform we're not getting no
mainstream final fantasy
so so yeah you can get all squeaking in
these trump change
like you can get my my my couch cushion
quarters
we have seen that like with the outer
worlds they will work with them on game
pass so yeah yeah okay
tell us why
no no no i i keep hearing you guys
captain for elder ring
and every time i hear people say
they need to do this they never do
like they just never do
and and
it makes logical sense right
and i wish they would make logical sense
right i wish they would see they did
cash sitting over there and say you know
what this makes logical sense let's go
do this right this makes logical sense
this is what they're screaming for oh
this will shut the door on a foot let's
do this
they won't
you know they won't
you know what they might do king that
since they have all that money
you want to invest it into stuff and not
necessarily buy something like that i
mean like an acquisition like an
acquisition like i said like that's how
you deflect shell game
yeah okay
that's not gonna that's not gonna stop
this right see what's what what's this
is
you have a a hole
inside yo yo because they have the mumps
up there and they know what's gonna be
placed in what yeah right and they say
okay so stalker tunes we got a little
sticky board yeah okay so stalker two
falls out of here what do we place in
here because we have to keep these dudes
satisfied because yes don't don't don't
ever forget
this is the money yes you gotta feed the
beast gotta feed the beast that is gay
gotta feed this bag we gotta we gotta
make sure that when it comes around time
to re-up these dudes is back to the
re-up yes okay so
dying light too they like that that's
not gonna cost too much put that in
there plus we did finance them to get
them over the hump
don't ever forget that part do you think
that if they would have got something
like dying like we would know by now
though king because that's not that long
away
but look how long they waited i mean
let's be honest with rainbow six
attractions that was super last minute
no but we they still bought it because
we showed it beginning of the month a
little bit
you don't remember they showed it on
their show then they showed on you
yeah you might be right you might be
right i can't remember so it's a lot of
things that they're still working on a
couple of times
conferences
ubisoft
didn't
finish
what they were doing didn't finish
when you play and what what what what
deals they're working with yeah you know
there's a lot of stuff that they can
plug and play in these months right like
you can put assassin's creed
this this this last one that came out on
the system launch it didn't get the game
pass yet correct so you can plug that in
there and remember they did show it at
the third party um
event so there's a lot of things that
you can plug in these places i'm just
telling y'all because i keep hearing
anything ring i it makes sense to me
right
they're not doing stuff that makes sense
certain times i
i actually feel like elden ring would be
a better game than dying like just
because they're lacking in that genre in
general yes i agree i say yes because
they got a lot of stuff i mean i don't
know but they honestly feel like dying
light is probably the best zombie but
i'm not the dying light's probably the
better fit the question also too is you
got to remember this is a two-way street
right and the fact that we don't know
how much band that namco gonna want for
that and microsoft may say look
that is a great game but based on the
engagement that we're looking for that
man
right so that that's the other thing but
let me let me get hustle and shout out
for motivation what's up you know what
i'm saying dmv stand up you know what i
mean but um what you thinking man like
obviously the star what do you feel
about stalker 2 delay
is it a serious hit to you for the first
half of xbox 2022 oh shaking his head
very profusely and um you know just in
general like what do you think the first
half because the people who do have
concerns like me about the first half of
22 like what do you think they should do
um the stalker two delay i'm not like a
stalker okay okay um what's the other
one metro last like that that was never
my thing anyway so like i'm cool with
the delay just make sure that that comes
out right because it's correct you have
to like live up to a certain reputation
if your xbox and i'll answer your other
question in a minute as far as the
delays
you they straight don't like just
look they're about to have so much in
like the if not if not this year the
next year mm-hmm um
xbox can kind of what's up you ain't
worried about what february you wait
real quick before
you go like yes sir i feel like
let's take away february like there's
one thing that we are
need to remember this is the beginning
of the generation and you don't want to
let your the gas up because all it takes
is one slip up and they've always said
whoever wins that first couple years of
the generation they win the entire rest
of it
uh peter moore or was it yeah everything
was peter said he said i think he said
first of ten minutes
well i mean xbox sadly lost that battle
but like here's the thing february that
wasn't gonna be able to do nothing about
that anyway horizons dropped in february
right but that that's a wrap anyway um
elder ring you know nothing i don't even
know elder ring cat like that's that's
eric and then they play all that
vendetta shout out to them
that's them yeah that's that ain't my
life
yo that game getting delayed okay all
right cool like what else got delayed
for xbox next year because i'm i i was i
did the podcast with that shout out to
the attic show
but the rumor the rumor is
that that's thank you started hey okay
so is it is it kind of like
can we really talk about rubrics that
the whole started like can we really
listen man
i hear things sometimes i'm not saying
i'm no inside of them
well i didn't want to say this i mean it
look it does look bad if you don't if
like your premiere like xbox title
doesn't release with starfield up until
november next year man like that it
looked bad but you know if it's around
june-ish to where everything starts
rolling out then that's it y'all chill
okay they just shipped like 12 then they
just shipped like 12-13 million i'm not
worried about the consoles i'm just
worried about keeping people in game
pass like this is what they
you know this is what they're promoting
and at the end of the day
you know you got to kind of keep a
cadence you know some things and not to
mention that the articus thing seems
like it's about to start popping like
they're starting to take those cards out
of shells like you do that when you're
about to start doing something with that
so i'm gonna put a poll in
um
king what what's the game that you would
want for them to put in game pass
oh the ring elder okay what about you
that's not elderly you know it's you
know hustle
um
if if you look at the most exciting
titles that people are excited for like
really excited for
this year
starfield
and eldon ring
all right horizon
i'm not really that excited for because
like i told you
it put me to sleep half the time oh man
okay i'm gonna say this i'm going to say
this
i'm gonna say this let's go
that's a game that i'm going to get
because i have to put my playstation in
motion
you understand like i have to put my
playstation in motion is this like
service you got to power it up no
you know what
these are electronics if you don't use
them don't go back
all right so again i i don't i don't
know
they said there's a certain shelf life
on this dude and i need to have them i
need him to live up to his expectations
so he he need to be great i'm waiting
for greatness to show up and hopefully
it'll show up in february but i'm saying
real quick yes real quick because i do
want to get the
the actual audience in here um
picked elder ring what game would you
want them to get because i'm about to
put a pole me honestly i want them to
get
or i'll do one that we get l ring but
dying light probably makes the most
sense it's gonna happen all right hustle
what game do you want
you know i'm undecided on that because
what third-party games are coming that
wasn't what i asked you
all right we'll see now let's see now
i'm going to answer the question the way
that i originally got it
what i would like to see over there on
the xbox side it's god of war ragnarok
but we know that that's not gonna happen
so so now you reached it now you're
reaching out you're taking the choice
you're taking the question you're
ripping it get them hustled that's right
well
i honestly um
it's not that they don't need anything i
feel like game pass at least the way i
use it it's a lot for like co-op
experiences like okay halo infinite like
red fall would be a good one like
something like that as long as they can
continue with stuff like that they'll
just roll in with the multiplayer or the
co-op side of things then i'm i'm
straight on that like
destiny two the witch queens your pick
okay
here we go there you go there you go
highly disrespectful we'll continue over
look you know i finished my thought
because uh i
understand hustle's point though and you
know he's like basically hustle you got
a lot of powers
like basically your mentality is like yo
stan pat you don't need to overreact
kind of kind of is that is that kind of
the vibe you get i'm getting from you
this won't be a big show i'm accurate
with what you i think expressing i think
hustle thinks it's so dominant like they
don't need to make a whole lot of like
they're already dominant but here's the
thing
we we haven't seen what xbox really has
to offer until we see perfect dawg until
we see those other highly anticipated so
i can get i'll completely get on my pass
right now plus you know it ain't really
much they can do about like a god of war
that's dropping that's supposed to be
dropping this [ __ ] right now
too much okay so you're thinking pat you
just came over for great you just came
off a great 20 21 ain't no need
basically like yo ain't no need to panic
ain't no need to stress like if you're
good yeah cog and if you know the rumors
that we have been hearing on twitter
from like mario 64 yeah or neville or if
that's true then they really straight
then they're doing a lot better than i
expected they're not personally
expecting something yeah what was these
rumors sir
apparently xbox ships i think 13. oh you
mean the numbers you're talking about
yeah you talk about the number okay you
you you like they come with the company
okay i mean that's that's yes
okay
all right it real quick i was just gonna
say if you want to get a couple of these
super chats yeah let me start stacking
up before you go ahead and say you're
going to say you're thinking i can't get
it i got to get my balls after that
that's that that that 15 million and 12
million
that's ancillary to to to the real
numbers the real numbers is that game
pass man like everybody keeps
i don't care about uh the 12 million
xboxes or the or the 12.
playstations that are sold those are old
metrics
and everybody gets caught up in these
old numbers
look at these engagement numbers because
15 million people playing forza horizon
that counts
because when they go and they buy stuff
and they get stuff in the store and they
go to do these things
i'm telling you right now you know yeah
that stuff adds up yeah and it starts to
add up to a point where and and hold on
a second
it adds up to a point where okay it's
like when you go in the club they let
you in the club free before 11 o'clock
right you didn't have to pay the the the
50 cover charge as you walk in yeah i go
to clubs that's 50 dollars so you know
you're getting paid
you know the cover charge to get inside
the club right so you got in the club
with your fifty dollars tucked right so
what you already said to yourself when
you walked in the club i got fifty
dollars to vlog
right so all right so you already know
drinks before 11 is eight bucks after 11
is 16. oh i'm a drink before 11.
okay so i'ma get slushy
on my 50 bucks that i walked in the door
with
now you slushy it's past 11.
you're already spending that 50 on all
these skins and all these little exotic
emojis on stupid stuff that you
purchased because you got in there for
free right
after 11
now the clock is ticking right because
the price went up on the brick right and
these boosters out here charging you and
you just didn't even know cause you turn
it up in the club cause you got in there
for free anyway and you didn't know
they're already hustling your wallet
so
this is the real number
so these dudes keep out here talking
about oh that's not sold and this is not
this stop watching everybody's pockets
but look at what they're doing while
they're inside this club
million people inside this club
somebody's buying drinks
you know what i see when i see that like
the 16 million stuff like when people
play 16 i see 16 million people that
play forza horizon
that are very comfortable with the money
they put in the gameplay oh it's like
official
it's just like you know when you see
those numbers like people call those are
sales numbers those are satisfied
customers i would say for the most part
that probably not leaving that service
next month like no absolutely i mean
look it's a good point said i understand
king's overall point that is the number
that is most important to microsoft they
they're more important about that
engagement and that game past subscriber
number i totally understand what he said
what i wanted to get back to again we
were talking about that lineup we said
january for game pass looks lit you know
february we don't know as much because
just crossfire x and again in my opinion
that ain't enough when you got horizon
zero doing you still need to be in the
zeitgeist in my opinion march tunic love
it we could be potentially indie but
in my opinion
not enough you will need something else
to drop with that then obviously as
addict
eloquently called me out you know the
rumors of a potential red fall delay
which was another game that was supposed
to be in that summer that first half you
know so to me that's how i look at it i
look and it's not like it's got to be
take fatter sony to this so you got to
do this i'm not i'm not on that right
but
i'm looking at the whole when you look
at ps5 the uncharted whatever is it the
collections whatever it is that's coming
out you got i'm i'm day one sifu i know
people laughing but sifu is me you know
what i'm saying then you got horizon
forbidden west that's a monster that's a
monster people fell asleep on the first
one that's a monster and they look good
then you got gran turismo right that's
coming you know what i'm saying king
your knees please i don't know
it's gonna
spoken we have michael on you know what
i'm saying black female protagonist you
know gary wood in them guys shout out to
those guys they're kind of funny they
did the writing you know saying
ghostwire tokyo comes out it's a stacked
year man
and then we i know people like not to
mention that that that game that's made
by the awful uh well
to them absolutely i don't know what
they did you all know who they ran over
your tires or whatever they did to you
that's your business we are not doing
that
but god kicked your cat yeah
but god of war you know what i'm saying
is out there so that's pretty much i i
just wanted to know look they they've
got that xbox you know money that
finance is available for gay pass it's
going to be curious to see how they
utilize it if they utilize it and like
what attic said i also agree which is
now be a time if there's nothing you're
going to fill it with that'll be a time
to make an acquisition
now we're trying to get people hyped up
but let's get these separate money i
know i know why can't you pass money
it's games it's good money acquisition
money is acquisition money and okay so
go i have a lot of people that sit down
inside my dms and this one dude it's
very very
king so what is what do you know
do you think they can come out right now
they're going to come out right now
they're going to say it right now
they have just acquired these people and
don't say nothing i said that's not how
business works
and public companies have to go public
and tell yes because that's insider
trading so you can't be acquiring people
and keep having it in tuck and don't say
nothing
you know what's funny about that um
during the game awards shout out to
colin moriarty i just listened to like
the most recent episode of defining duke
tencent had another name it was called
like level select the song oh
level infinite i believe or something
like that yeah when but i didn't know
that that was tension nothing i got any
particular issue it's like yo just keep
it real just say who you are but they've
tried to flip them yeah they make movies
too you know that right yeah outside
they made that monster hunter movie yeah
they're outside
what you really have to see i didn't
want to go too deep with that um
no no no no no no no no i didn't want to
go too deep into uh
how certain companies uh form our
choices when we were picking our
characters because that that was a like
a whole rabbit hole and i decided to go
down that earlier but um
back to what microsoft is going to do
okay
the acquisition money
they are probably in talks with people
of course right so
okay so this is how you keep something
from com from coming out everybody have
non-disclosure contracts uh you can't
talk about it but these papers will be
signed on this day we're in negotiations
with whoever so this is how you can keep
something from not going public right
and then y'all can sign it and then you
can go public with it right so you don't
hurt them and put them in your pocket
and don't say nothing that's not how it
works so the money is over here for that
and i'm pretty sure that they have uh
are in talks with acquiring a couple of
more uh
and i think it's publishers
it has to be somebody big
um
but these games that they're going to
put in they're going to start slotting
games into these uh parts because i've
noticed
it's one one
get the damn slide please
cause there's a lot of gaps without your
slide
[Laughter]
slot game
so
i i expect them
for every month you have
one
medium to large uh title division going
inside the situation and then you have a
bunch of little ancillary games inside
because i find myself playing more indie
titles than i've ever played in my life
now with game pass off of the simple
fact that oh i'm gonna try or whatever
and see how it goes and plus i talk to
you guys with it and work it that way
but i see them doing that throughout the
year and hustle is kind of right um when
they look at
uh
falls i mean horizon coming on in
february
they looked at it as they say okay well
they didn't have a horizon
in november right they didn't have a
horizon in december right
you know in these months is the months
that we were leading so again this is a
month that we gonna have to eat bread
and toast
you know
this this is what this this is
this this the ramen noodle month right
here
we won't let them do they think so
that's how it was very vocal on how they
shouldn't have been that open to take
that criticism
so i'm not gonna just like keep quiet
like if if i was on sony back then to to
amp up stuff and not go that many months
without anything any type of game any
type of news i'm not going to let
microsoft just get away with the two
likes
i agree look this is it's a fun to see
let's get these super chats we do got to
move on but um i will jump in right
quick i believe it's christopher jetzer
he says fortnite chapter three is unreal
engine five okay raiden blade with the
five pound super chat king what's the
ps5 exclusive for the delays unreal
engine 5 not used on any playstation 5
in-house titles for stalker delay it it
for stalker delay it until it's ready
but xbox will fund more games i i will
only read stuff that you miss uh okay a
member for six months enough for spec
king uh bunty enough for spontaneous
preach 32 games coming to game pass who
cares about first party when you're
playing everything else can't wait to
listen later okay christopher jetzer two
dollar super chat tiny tina wonderlands
march good multiplayer okay okay that's
that's a huge five we got a member for
five months people can't talk to them
they got away with it but they ain't
getting away with it uh
t-rex voice what y'all do keep killing
it lawrence ps5 is holding back
oh my god
southern view raider blade with a two
pound super chat square enix can keep
final fantasy series for all i care oh
he upset all right bunty five dollar
super chat why everybody care about
first party so much when the first party
games is not the ones that's really
selling as much as third-party games
interesting christian christian g 20
super chat gents i love you all been
listening the last two years on spotify
just here to plug my people too
playstation 5 master race laugh out loud
love i love my xbox too just kidding i
love them all that's the master race
console master race hello
bang uh christian g i like that i like
that raiden blade five pound super chat
they wanna snub xbox fans and money fine
keep it and the end square will bend the
knee if i was xbox i would say no you
snubbed my gamers two years and wait he
ain't liking that final fantasy
situation
i don't care if you want to date me now
later you're going to date me we got it
we got 18 months the wise old gamer
[Music]
18 months for the wizo gamer i want king
to say they told him don't you ever come
around here don't don't want to see your
face you better disappear the fire in
their eyes and their words are really
clear so beat it just beat it
dude
so you got the white jacket
remember the beginning of 2021
playstation 5 was a shoot we all know
how it really went though
playstation 5 could take february but we
know xbox is inevitable shout out to
thatos quotes okay
out here snapping people away all right
all right attacking people playstations
turned into series s's
i can't and then he said again find out
super chat down in taco and i mean fight
for second place because nintendo has 20
22 or lock and it's not even close as
long as breath of the wild to release
the switch game coming in hot i see you
switch games
man that 480i is crazy
aggressive go ahead
shout out to lens crafters
i kid
that's all i got look it's going to be
very interesting to monitor
yeah let me get the face the face out to
the face 23 bkny 29 all that talk about
forza 5 and halo infinite xbox winning
holidays playstation for 2022 says hold
my beer he said you would pop it off
king now what 20 22 what's up oh i'm
gonna get a playstation 4.
hold that beer
you're clearly king it doesn't seem like
they do want you to get a playstation 4.
they're keeping they keep making them yo
hey
can i speak on that really quick yes
please that's not the first time we've
heard like playstation continue in their
consoles or rather discontinuing their
concerts so soon they did the same thing
with the ps2 when appearances are you
ruining our jokes
it's just not ruining the joke
he said stop bringing it to your face
i'll bring it in your facts
no listen listen uh on on god in them
they understand jim is gonna make sure
he make this money these games is coming
up
on both platforms baby he's gonna sell
it to you brother hook a crook
somebody get these games you know you
need a boat baby i should i should just
sell my ps5 because i should just play
the god of war on my pc yeah you're
ridiculous you know what you know what
they're investing into the mobile market
yeah i just play god of war on my online
on the messiness anyway i never even got
a chance to address god of war on pc the
definitive edition i never got a chance
to tell you that it's best controlled
with an xbox controller because you know
why
and i'm gonna tell you somebody told me
oh it's not the xbox platform
because it's the pc
all right fool
what controller are you using
are you hooking up your playstation 4
controller
did your playstation 5 controller start
working in the dark at night it didn't
so when you hit that button and i i love
the devs
over there is santa monica that said yo
i love that the world can play now
with an xbox controller that's not what
they say shout out
to the xbox dude that gets the chance to
control cradles for power
you know you know what king
it's a shame they should have did what
they should have what they were supposed
to do they should have let their
commercials they were supposed to
promote that cur they were supposed to
promote that god awards saying if you
want the best experience you got to have
that duel
wow
that's what they want
what they should have did was they
should have got me to do the commercial
and said if you want the best experience
get a pc with an xbox controller
i
and this time you can actually have it
in true 4k widescreen with hdr with no
frame drops and maybe you can change the
color on the ogre
look man
look normally i'm there with you about
going out here with you too
we having control
i don't know man
let's go let's go let's go playstation
foolishness
you know why your controller's there
because you're not playing anything
[Music]
all i'm saying is this is a good
controller like it is it's beautiful
there's a paperwork of a chat [ __ ] just
wants to kick that chat hey king goony
goo good
[Laughter]
coming back for kick again five super
chat breath of the wild two can be 360p
25 frames per second it is still going
to be a better game than ragnarok and
horizon film west if they were 8k 120
frames per second gameplay is the only
thing that matters switchgate oh oh
hustle coming wait wait wait it'll
outsell those games for sure now i will
say that nintendo fans they will they
will pull up for breath of the wild too
it won't be better
from the wise old gamer didn't spartacus
play with the whole team oh my god
moving on next last time we gonna get
out of cuz they're getting crazy messy
and y'all getting ridiculously messy
yes um look man hit me hit me in three
is my topic um year two
ton of new announcements you know
including hitman trilogy the entire
trilogy two game pass tons of new modes
and then also what i thought was
interesting was um hitman vr coming in
pc you know obviously lord oculus is
going to find out you know a little
interested in that but um yes don't know
it looks like it's no longer exclusive
to psvr right now so all i wanted to
know what you felt about the hitman
announcements and then io interactive as
a whole so uh let's start let's not
hustle man let's get you in here first
hustle what you think okay
uh good for game pass um i have never
been really interested in the stealth
games in particular the only stealth
game that i can halfway stand is the
last of us
um
this is good for game pass um we y'all
was talking earlier about like what what
can xbox kind of counteract with
harass excuse me horizon forbidden wes
was doing this this is one of the ways
that you can do that and um i want to
say my my co-host with the most over
there
didn't you mention that um i don't want
to active is rumored to be purchased by
microsoft oh yeah
no i don't know if he i don't know if he
started this yeah let's get an article
this is super good right ryan feel free
to write article about that though so
[Laughter]
i demand the same treatment
[Laughter]
today
cool man i'll just finish it up by
saying hey you know that this is variety
and while i'm still i'm on game pass for
the ten dollars a month as long as it
comes to pc and the port is working fine
yeah i'll give it a try um didn't one of
those hitman feature um
uh what's whole buddy of jerry bean
daniel bean he played uh he played
traveling in double 07 gold now you know
i know
you had um
there was like a joke going around a
week like you you killed him in golden
eye double o seven did you kill him
again
as long as all of that stuff is there
i'll try at the very least but i i ain't
a superhero man dude but this is good
for like everybody who likes to steal
stuff and with the way that um hitman
was released yeah i know it was released
in season so yeah everything being there
you can literally start from the
beginning
you guys like bringing up the
like aisle
like
the only reason i think that it might be
a little bit possible that they bought
io is because they have that project
dragon or whatever it's called right
right
and i feel like it's weird that
hitman 3 just didn't go in there the
whole trailer
because to me i feel like
you could easily just get
hit man three and that would that would
have been enough that would cause white
yes
but the fact that they put all the other
two back in there and it could be
literally just one of those things where
it's a coincidence you know yeah but i i
i don't think there's a whole lot of
fruit to that but i do think that
there might be something there i just
don't know it but you know what the the
the funny thing is like
now that you guys mentioned i interact
with hitman we've always said they need
a comic book movie a game
let them make a punisher oh that'd be
fire i'll be because i feel like iowa
interactive could make a punishment we
do know they got uh like to what hustle
would say they got a double double a
double 007 game
in um development and i think that's
actually a perfect fit obviously you'd
hit man the correlation there but yeah
look i i like i got my balls i want king
to get it it's off because um yeah man
what are you thinking and also king with
the uh the vr portion i want your
thoughts on that because previously
hitman was exclusive to psvr
you know i'm saying that that way
you know so it's like i don't like his
mouth right now he's doing too much with
the smile with the mouth right now
he's doing way too much of his mouth um
but it's like you know i thought that
was interesting because again coming to
steamboat they said they're gonna have
more announcements
laters for our specific platform so
let's get into it game pass the vrt
though i warned you
he's a bond villain
[Laughter]
yes what you thought it was safe
philadelphus
dominance
aurelius spencer does it again
every time you doubt me
i told you different things that he
would do
i told you
this would be the most successful xbox
so
in saying this that means it will be
more successful than the 360.
in saying that that 360 mop the floor
with you
ma
molly whap y'all got psd
all over ptsd all over that that right
there you don't remember that that whole
generation y'all was just running around
this is what made y'all crazy this is
what you're crazy
that 360 made y'all crazy and you know
what happened we had the finger roll we
messed it up with johnny he told xbox
what was the layup for the dick
it wasn't a place to be
by y'all right y'all was supposed to be
the pc engine if y'all don't know who
the pc engine was that was turbo
graphics that was pc engine was the most
dominant platform in japan
and they not they're gone a footnote in
history
you're not going to recover from this
one
okay so
i o interactive i'm a little bit
different than attic right
that's a publisher right mm-hmm
they're deaf i believe yeah they do and
they also publish their games yeah you
could be right i forget now
now i want you to think about this part
this is business
you can you easily have part three
you don't need to have the whole kit in
caboodle
why would you have to have the whole kit
in caboodle
what would that be for
oh
could that be uh prelude to some other
deal some other partnership something
else that's down the line um we got it
we know about the project yeah they're
working on yeah
why would you give this in this manner
that's something else to look at
but
the vr portion yeah let's get to that
i'm curious what you think about that
what i like is
playstation locked this down for such a
long period of time yes
now it's going to be free to flourish
it didn't
grow anything over there
and
and this is what i'm saying i'm saying
this part for this okay
locking down stuff to your platform
and it doesn't change things
as detrimental to the game
now it's going to hit steam and it's
going to go all over and everybody's
going to partake in this thing now i can
see if it grew the platform in some form
or fashion and playstation vr went on to
become a super successful platform it
became a niche platform and didn't grow
out of that niche right right because
vr is niche i want to see
what other platforms it goes to
other than steam i'm with you because
i'm highly anticipating it uh i can do
airlink um
but i'm highly anticipating
if they say oculus i'm highly
anticipating if they because
do you take that software and you
release it to everybody because it's
been on under shackles for so long so
they it was it was revenue that could
have been made in other areas and again
i'm gonna tell you guys
what's old to you is new to somebody
that never tried it
so if it's on oculus new
imma purchase it i'm gonna check it out
right so i wanted my curiosity because
i'm an oculus owner
do we get a chance to participate i made
a question now they said in the they
said they was
when they were showing the footage of
them showing the hitman 3 and vr and now
remember it's not only just three it's
hitman one through three now also coming
to pc vr they're supposed to announce
the platform but was interested people
said they saw htc them using that as
well as an oculus um
rift
so it is curious to see you know what
platforms it does come to and if if it
does come out because of course got to
be a little biased there that is the
home team for me right but um i i am
very curious to see if it will be an air
link situation shot the ksrt in there or
will it be a dedicated oculus version
where you won't even need like how
resident evil is right resident evil you
download you win you don't got to do any
type of in-link to a pc wirelessly or
whatever so that that part is curious
but i got to ask you a question though
because we've been speculating on this
whole i o
and they've been obviously playing nice
with xbox right we heard about the
project dragging or whatever they got
something cooking you know they got a
double 07 game the question i have was
on the vr side very curious what you
think
you mentioned the whole part about vr
and psv psvr they wanted to expand past
and obviously want the game to expand
more maybe didn't do the numbers that
they maybe they anticipated
right but let's just say microsoft does
acquire them right
do you think that shuts down
vr
from other
platforms you know because we had we but
we had to think about this we had
bethesda they was in vr before they got
acquired they had the skyrim running
around
and we had no more vr talk from a
potential right not saying that it's
definitely shut down but i'm curious to
you that if io was hypothetically
acquired would their vr stuff
be kind of stopped if they're under
microsoft i i don't i don't think so um
i think i had talked about this on game
on daily
um
i i don't think microsoft shuts down the
vr talk
they're not in the vr space okay that i
don't think they limit the devs on
uh what products or what what what um
yeah what products they can uh
develop
in on their side right you know so
when they're making a game they look at
all the possibilities of selling right
and they give these possibilities to
microsoft okay so uh this is we can do
this for pc this this and the thirds
this is the scale down all right uh oh
okay so uh does this transfer well to
cell phones does this transfer welder
tablets and stuff like this right all
right we have to make sure that it's
scalable for this just that the third
right
vr is always a possibility as well
so
and
um what asa was talking about it's not
just a switch that they just hit the
switch in the game
in vr no you have to actually from the
ground up make sure
in mind all right
um
so i honestly believe
that they don't just shut them down i
think those things could be an act of
development i just don't think those
things are talked about because that's
not the avenue where they pursue right
now right so i don't want to say like
microsoft uh because from all the stuff
that we hear
microsoft allows the companies to be
them right but if they're not pursuing
any vr endeavors i don't think we're
ever going to hear anything about vr
until they are in that area yeah just a
curious question because i was wondering
you know a shout out to ksanti in the
chat on me he was like you talking about
saying hey clocks are point ninja theory
had hellblade vr i don't see them doing
anything more with that but it is
curious to see if if they are required
and it's a studio that has interest in
vr if it would be stopped but it could
be to your point king like they may look
at that as like pc and the mobile and a
separate thing and maybe they'll say oh
you still allowed to do that as long as
it's not with another you know console
platform you know what i'm saying like a
playstation oh dude would it ever go to
playstation no no
let's game passes over there
i knew that was coming eddie
about his vr thing and what just what
you felt about that in general
and and different um if
microsoft well would you guys have
brought up examples to where bethesda
was working on something that didn't
come out same name with um ninja theory
but
if they were to have something dropped
yeah i feel like it's the minecraft
effect the well they'll let it go
everywhere seeing how they don't have a
vr device of their own and i don't know
and i don't think they'll even get into
it i think that they that might be a
little too far yeah it might be it might
be too far gone it might be you might
you know it might be over for them
before they even get started and i don't
think that they'll waste resources into
that in my my personal perfect opinion
fair enough i'll get my balls off we get
out of here um yeah i think this is a
great move hitman you know the trilogy i
think that that's powerful it's one of
the best stealth games shout out to mr
maddie plays me and manny we go hard for
him man man it is it's it's the last of
a dying breed the true stealth you know
i'm saying the true you know kind of do
things your own way manipulate you know
everything how you want to do it with
any no preset paths to graphics i like
that glacier engine i think that engine
be really rocking you know what i'm
saying and they always look good xbox
always remember when xbox scorpio the
l1x they had their enhancements to 60
frames they always seem to work well
with xbox whenever they want to do any
type of um technical upgrades or
advances they seem to work nice with
them i like them i like them in the
studio i'm always big fan of stealth so
if anything ever happened with i o and
them hey i wouldn't be opposed i think
it's it's a nice fit i want to know a
project that dragon and i think they're
perfect for a double 07 game so let's
see what happens man but that's what i
got let's get a bone out of here um yeah
we got the pole actually
actually i'll get the let me get the
poll then i'll get some chats afterwards
but um
new ilp
poll with the recent delay to the xbox
times exclusive stalker 2. do you think
xbox needs to bolster their first half
of 2022 software lineup the choices are
a
yes continue to boast the game pass with
big triple a third party games day and
date like elder ring dying light etc
b
hustle like this no stay in pack they
still potentially have red fields red
fall star field and forza motorsport
coming in 2022
c be aggressive with studio acquisitions
especially if games are not ready this
year wb games etc or d i don't care none
of it matters anymore because console
sales for xbox are now lit
shout out to all
those go rocks
[Laughter]
[Music]
using your influence on the masses
yourself but let me get this on these
last couple of super chats and uh we
would get up out of here oh this got my
man we got phase we got um [ __ ] we got
done we got wazzo gamer 2000 jack didn't
spartacus play with the whole team i
think i got that flame two dollars a
chair i'll agree gameplay is king if you
can see it lol he coming at donald taco
for that that's besties
while you play uh-oh oh donald taco
coming
every game is every game is still trying
to play cat every game still trying to
play catch up to the first breath of the
wild the second one won't even be in the
same competition with the hustle which
you think
he's right and um don i'm gonna need for
you to use your influence and tell
everybody else to buy the new metroid
game that came out oh apparently they
hit three million
stop playing with me though
you know
don't come for me unless he said for you
okay got it
laugh out loud whether you play on an
xbox or windows pc you are still a
microsoft customer this argument is
invalid all right har geet shani with
the 10 super chat come on with the words
funny logic okay games need to look good
pay attention to every detail don't talk
to me about gameplay don't tell me a
game should be fun the grass needs to
look good do you see the peach fuzz okay
he being out of control but it is what
it is and uh let's see if i miss any
other thing okay we got necromancer and
i think that we i think that was the
last one yeah after what you got so
necromancer my man we got you zell with
the final super chat great show and
great guess another awesome show law so
i think alex may have had the least i
don't know if he's still there to do his
outro but hustle and motivate man thanks
for pulling up holding us down man
what's up i had to get out of here but
what's going on with you by the way can
i find people find you what you got
going on man
all i'm gonna say is uh good night guys
all right you gotta go you gotta go he
got planes to land he gotta get k kings
xbox game pass playing to be landed
continue with that jacket
you know that jacket he landed man
i gotta throw
just stood in youtube hustling motivate
um i'm actually gonna be back uh
february 15th got some family stuff
there okay got a real big thing that's
happening
somebody in my family so we're gonna
push with that okay um
february 18th though hey i don't care
where y'all at where y'all following me
at streaming horizon zero down to okay
listen i'm gonna run through that i'm
gonna run through that mercury's telling
me things about horizon zero dawn one i
don't care i don't care what he's
talking about i'm the day one on that
one
thank y'all for having me um shout out
to miss micah um you know yeah
that's you know the the goddess the rpg
correct yeah
yeah
yeah that's you know that's that's kind
of like a rare breed because i don't i
don't really meet so many people who run
jrpgs but she mentioned persona earlier
i said yeah she's cool
i started this in the super chat asking
what she thought a lady and but i didn't
want to get my feelings
but thank y'all for having me uh shout
out to you know addict you know you put
the back signal up i pull it up um y'all
catch me tuesday uh testing tuesday's on
the islo's channel uh the attic show
okay the one i think we got we got some
some special things coming and um good
luck to the 49ers before we go oh thank
you brother thank you washed it off i
appreciate you indeed because i i hate
dallas at all shout out to fame over
there
love fave but we got to get you
let's see what happens no doubt no doubt
hold on oh man they coming
donna tackle with the finals in the chat
hustle what's the ratcheted clank sales
looking like the top of the line ps5
exclusive got passed up by nintendo's 2d
side b-tier game
is he talking about animal crossing
because that joint also everything all
right look you got to hold that
sometimes you just got to hold that and
not say nothing
sometimes you gotta hold it then i say
no i'm talking about that metroid yeah
he talked about that
yeah
you talking about bachelor beat that
right that's what he's talking about
really i didn't know that yeah
he got his chest out you got to check
that and metroid eats outside it's
embarrassing
yo he don't got a plate in the house
on the porch
again what a shout out to mama micah for
pulling up she was absolutely amazing
last day of media family great game in
history she put a tweet out so talk
about she had an absolutely fantastic
time go support her she's out here
killing it hardcore gamer and uh
hopefully we'll have her back again lord
i'd kept the bounce butter king man
where can you find people find you what
you got going on sir
you can catch me on twitter
meeting people up all day
you've been having a football twitter go
in there people you guys already know i
don't beat up all your generals
there is no one left
i'm literally standing up there and i'm
asking is there anyone else are we doing
the choice right now
anyone else hector he said he said he
said
that guy is the biggest man i've ever
seen
i
[Laughter]
[Music]
they they scared to death so y'all
understand that i'm 96 96 right all the
time
and when i told you what was gonna
happen it didn't happen and you hurt so
i love it and
and i just want to give a shout out uh
to uh mama micah yes
for showing up
and with her first earning bucks she
purchased an xbox and she went with
greatness and i if you she put the
battery in my back today bruh
like yo she she she gave me the spark
that i needed because i came in on a low
battery cell and then she she sparked
the guard ah i had to hit that pally
pellet see what y'all don't even know
chris oh that's crazy that's right
that's chris people don't know how much
that's that's that's all boys
chris
chris every week
i'm gonna give you i'm gonna give you
this for the spaces dudes
i tell you spices dude don't want to do
spaces on me so i'm gonna give you 30 30
days of king
okay okay longer than your drought for
your playstation games
yeah yeah real quick shout out to uh hip
hop gamer um
he had actually had a prediction that
around the time the ps5 was coming out
about the backwards compatibility yeah
with the ps5
it looks like that's about to be true
and some certain stuff right here
yeah yeah there there are some some uh
major news outlets actually reporting on
what okay
okay i'll just say i'll just say i'll
just say i wanna i want to give him a
minute do the back compatibility stuff
but you're paying for it yeah he called
me the paper that's what he care about
i don't care how they do it what they do
or how they say it boy
they gonna drop it at the drop of a dog
[Laughter]
you better drop this
right there oh yeah man look we got some
fun stuff i get shot about my mic
we got some fun stuff planned for
february march to stay tuned it's gonna
be lit
fun guess y'all gonna be ready it's i
can't wait but look that's all i got
anybody got anything else before we get
up out of here
nope you're on twitter
everybody enjoy your sunday
peace
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
you